ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BASE
BACKER FORGES BRADFORD BY ADAM
CORTEZ THREE DALLY DODD DURAZO
AIKMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ GROWTH
HURTS BERG WENT SO HER TADO
JONES CAM WALKER LAYERED LEYVA
LIN'AN MCGUIRE MELINDA'S MAN.
NEWMAN NIELSEN A CHILL UP BOTH
HANDS FOURTEEN TINA BROCK RUBIO
SKINNER STERN NUMBERED BY CAL
SKI. WEINER WELL. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY A QUORUM IS
PRESENT MEMBERS CONGRATULATIONS
ON BEING BACK AT YOUR DESK I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU EACH TO GO TO
YOUR DESK AND I WOULD LIKE OUR
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE RISE. WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR LEE MOMENT AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. BY SENATOR ROTH
SENATOR LOW MOAN. THANK YOU.
GRACIOUS GOD I HAVE NO IDEA
WHERE I AM GOING I DO NOT SEE
THE ROAD AHEAD OF ME. I CANNOT
KNOW FOR CERTAIN WHERE IT WILL
END. NOR DO I REALLY KNOW
MYSELF. AND THE FACT THAT I
THINK I AM FOLLOWING YOUR WILL
DOES NOT MEAN THAT I AM
ACTUALLY DOING SO. BUT I
BELIEVE THAT THE DESIRE TO
PLEASE YOU. DOES IN FACT PLEASE
YOU. AND I HOPE THAT I HAVE THE
DESIRE IN ALL THAT I AM DOING.
I KNOW BUT IF I DO THIS YOU
WILL LEAVE ME BY THE RIGHT
ROAD. THOUGH I MAY KNOW NOTHING
ABOUT IT. THEREFORE I WILL
TRUST YOU ALWAYS DO I MAY SEEM
TO BE LOST AND IN THE SHADOW OF
DEATH I WILL NOT FEAR FOR YOUR
EVER WITH ME. AND YOU WILL
NEVER LEAVE ME TO FACE MY
PERILS ALONE. AMEN. KELLY I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. YEAH THIS IS
ALL. MEMBERS WE'RE NOW GOING TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR
WAY SO. THE SENATE AT. STATE
SENATOR WAY SELF SENATE ENERGY
I'M HERE I'M RIGHT OVER HERE BY
THE WAY. SENATE ENERGY WILL BE
MEETING AND HALF AN HOUR AFTER
RECESS SENATE ENERGY WILL BE
MEETING AT HALF AN HOUR AFTER
WE RECESS WE CAN GET THE
MICROPHONES WORKING. AND THEN
ALSO I AM LOOKING FOR SENATOR
CORTESE PLEASE PROCEED. YES
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
DELIVER PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT. WILL MEET. AT TWO
THIRTY IN ROOM FOR TWO OR THREE
THANK YOU THINK CENTER CORTESE
MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL SIX PM THE TWO
POLICY COMMITTEES WILL MEET
DURING THIS RECESS. WE STAND IN
RECESS.
MEMBERS THE
SENATE WILL RECONVENE MEMBERS
THERE ARE MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. MADAM PRESIDENT I AM
DIRECTED TO INFORM YOUR
HONORABLE BODY THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ON THIS DAY PASSED
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THIRTY TWO.
SUE PARKER CHIEF CLERK OF THE
ASSEMBLY ORDERED HELD IT ASKS.
MADAM PRESIDENT I'M DIRECTED TO
INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND ON
THIS DAY PASSED AS AMENDED
SENATE BILLS. 1-391-402-1406
ONE FORTY SEVEN ONE FIFTY TWO
AND CENTEL ONE FIFTY EIGHT. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
HONORABLE BODY TO CONCURRENCE
THAT AMENDMENTS TO PARKER CHIEF
CLERK OF THE ASSEMBLY ABOVE
BILL'S ORDERED TWO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS FILE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A. B.
EIGHT THIRTY TIME EIGHT THIRTY
TWO THE FIRST TIME. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO AN ACT
RELATING TO TENANCY AND
DECLARING THEIR AGENCY THEY'RE
OUT SICK FOR TWO MEDIUM LENGTH.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION OUR FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS WILL BE CONSIDERATION
OF A V. EIGHT THIRTY TWO AND
AFTER THAT WE WILL MOVE TO THE
BUDGET PACKAGE BUT BEFORE WE
PROCEED WE WILL MOVE TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS FOR PROCEDURAL
PURPOSES. CENTER COVER HERE ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. AND
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. RESOLVED
THAT ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THIRTY
TWO. THE CENTER I'M SORRY YOU
NEED TO MAKE YOUR REQUEST I'M
JUST GETTING AHEAD OF US
SENATOR CAFIERO PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I MOVE TO
SUSPEND THE DRAFT RULES AND
SENATE RULES AS THEY RELATE TO
ASSEMBLY BILL. EIGHT THIRTY TWO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THIS IS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ONE FIRST IF YOU
DON'T MIND ABSOLUTELY. RESEND
THAT MEMBERS INSTEAD THERE IS A
RESOLUTION AT THE DESK
REQUESTING TO DISPENSE WITH
ARTICLE FOUR SECTION EIGHT B.
OF THE CONSTITUTION AS IT
RELATES TO SOMEBODY ABOUT EIGHT
THIRTY TWO THIS REQUEST HAS
BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. RESOLVED
RESOLVED AT THAT ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT THIRTY TO PRESENT A CASE
OF URGENCY AS THAT TERM IS USED
IN ARTICLE FOUR SECTION EIGHTY
OF THE CONSTITUTION. AND THE
PROVISION OF THAT SECTION
REQUIRING THAT THE BILL BE READ
ON THREE SEVERAL DAYS IN EACH
HOUSE IS HEREBY DISPENSED WITH.
AND IT IS ORDERED THAT SAID
BILL BE READ THAT THE SECOND
AND THIRD TIMES CONSIDERED
ENGROSSED AND PLACED ON UPON
ITS PASSAGE. THANK YOU SENATOR
WILL FOR PURPOSE TO RISE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. WE OBJECT
AND ASK FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE I
ASK FOR MY CAUCUS TO VOTE NO
THANK YOU SIR. SENATOR BYRD
HURTS FOR PURPOSE YOU RICE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
MAJORITY LEADER ASKS FOR A
FOREIGN HIGH VOTE AS MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS ARE CURRENTLY
ELIGIBLE FOR ASSISTANCE. AND
FACE EVICTION AND THIS MATTER
WAS HEARD IN THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY IN THE SUBSTANCE OF
THIS MATTER. HAS BEEN HEARD IN
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE ASKED FOR
AND I VOTE. THANK YOU. MR
MAJORITY LEADER IS ASKING FOR
AN I. VOTE THE MINORITY LEADER
IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA. HI ATKINS. I
BASE. NO BACKER HI FORGES NO
BRADFORD. HI BY ADAM ARE YOU
PROTESTING HI DALLY NO DOT. HI
THERE AWESOME HI ADNAN HI
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ HI GROVE.
NO ONE HURTS BERG HI WITH SO
WELL HI HER TADO HI JONES NO
CAN WONDER. I LAYERED I LLEVA
HI THE MON I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN HI NEWMAN I
NELSON NO A SHOW ABOUT. NO PAN
I FOURTEEN TO NO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN. HI
I'M BURKE I Y. CASKEY I WINNER
I WILL KNOW. FIVE THIRTY ONE
KNOWS NINE THE CONSTITUTION HAS
BEEN SUSPENDED WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK TO SENATOR CABALLERO
PLEASE PROCEED. MEMBERS I MOVED
TO THE TO SUSPEND THE GIANT
ROLLS AND SENATE RULES AS THEY
RELATE TO ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
THIRTY TWO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR KABIRU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. AT THE- SENATOR
WILK. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
ONCE AGAIN I. OBJECTS PLANTS
FOR ROLL CALL VOTE AND I
ENCOURAGE MY MEMBERS TO VOTE
NOW. THANK YOU SENATOR WILL.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING THE PREVIOUS ROLL CALL
VOTE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
FIVE THIRTY ONE KNOWS NINE THE
JOINT RULES HAVE BEEN SUSPENDED
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
CENTRE SKINNER CENTER SKINNER
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. SENATOR SKINNER THANK
YOU- MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TO-
MOVE TO SUSPEND THE SENATE
RULES AS THEY RELATE TO
ASSEMBLY BILLS. 1-291-391-4021.
461-407-1521 FIFTY EIGHT AND
ONE FIFTY NINE THANK YOU-SENATOR SKINNER CENTER WILL PRO
PURPOSE YOU WRITE A CAME OUT OF
PRISON ONCE AGAIN I DO OBJECT
AS FOR ROLL CALL VOTE ENCOURAGE
MY MEMBERS TO VOTE NO THANK YOU
CENTER WILL REMEMBERS IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE ROLL
CALL VOTE THAT WE HAVE
PREVIOUSLY USED. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE FIVE THIRTY ONE
KNOWS NINE THE RULES HAVE BEEN
SUSPENDED CENTERSTATE OR. THANK
YOU I HAVE A SECOND MOTION. AND
THAT IS THAT I MOVED JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA BE WAIVED FOR THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE TO MEET TO END HERE
ASSEMBLY BILLS ONE THREE THREE
ONE THREE EIGHT. 424-011-4031.
441-405-1408. ONE FORTY NINE
ONE FIFTY ONE FIFTY ONE. AND
ONE FIFTY THREE THROUGH ONE
FIFTY SEVEN ON WEDNESDAY JUNE
WITHOUT FOUR DAYS NOTICE IN THE
DAILY FILE. THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER SENATOR WILK THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT ONCE AGAIN I
ASK FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE AND
ENCOURAGE MY MEMBERS TO VOTE
NOW THANK YOU CENTER WELCOME
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING OUR PREVIOUS VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN BUYS
THIRTY ONE KNOWS NINE WE WAIVE
IT J. R. SIXTY TO EIGHTY EIGHT
TO ME AND HERE ON WEDNESDAY
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO
TO YOUR SUPPLEMENTAL FILE.
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE A
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE. WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH. FILE ITEM.
EXCUSE ME FILE ITEM. NINETY ONE
A. B. EIGHT THIRTY TWO. SENDER
CABALLERO. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO AN ACT
RELATING TO TENANCY AND
ACQUIRING THE URGENCY OF ARAB
STATES TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
MA'AM SECRETARY IF YOU READ
THAT AGAIN PLEASE. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO AN ACT
RELATING TO TENANCY IN
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
CENTRE COVER HERE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT A B. THREE EIGHTY
TWO EIGHT THIRTY TWO. THE NEXT
STEP IN ENSURING VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIA RENTERS ARE
PROTECTED AND LANDLORDS ARE
MADE WHOLE. I'D LIKE TO THINK
LEADERSHIP IN BOTH HOUSES AND
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE WORK
AND SUPPORT ON THIS REALLY
CRITICAL ISSUE. EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM KNOWS VERY WELL THE
STRUGGLES FAMILIES IN OUR
DISTRICTS FACE SHORTLY AFTER
THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC IN
MARCH OF LAST YEAR. WHEN THE
GOVERNOR DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND SHELTER IN PLACE
ORDERS ONE OF MY FIRST CONCERN.
WAS HOW PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY
FOR LAID OFF OR WERE PUT OUT OF
WORK. WOULD PAY THEIR RENT. PUT
FOOD ON THEIR TABLES OR KEEP
THEIR POWER AND WATER ON.
DESPITE THE MANY CHALLENGES
MANY RESIDENTS WERE FORTUNATE
TO HAVE SOME OF THEIR INCOME
SUPPLEMENTED BY UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BUT UNFORTUNATELY
CALIFORNIA'S LONGSTANDING
HOUSING CRISIS. AND EXTREME
RENT PRICES MEANT MANY WERE
LEFT UNABLE TO PAY THE RENT. IN
RESPONSE THE STATE STEPPED IN
AND PASSED THE FIRST EVICTION
MORATORIUM AB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT. FOLLOWED BY S. B. NINETY
ONE WHICH EXTENDED THE
MORATORIUM AND PROVIDED THE
FIRST RUN ROUND OF FUNDING. TO
RENTERS MOST IN NEED. NOW WITH
THE VACCINES PROVIDING IMMUNITY
WE FINALLY SEE THE LIGHT AT THE
END OF THE TUNNEL. MANY
SIGNIFICANT COVERT SAFETY
PROTOCOLS HAVE BEEN LIFTED MORE
PEOPLE ARE BACK TO WORK AND THE
ECONOMY IS SLOWLY RECOVERING.
DESPITE THE GOOD NEWS THERE IS
WORK TO BE DONE. A. B. EIGHT
THIRTY TO TAKE THE NEXT LOGICAL
STEP TO KEEP TENANTS FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS. AND HELP
LANDLORDS RECOVER DESPERATELY
NEEDED RENTAL INCOME.
SPECIFICALLY AB EIGHT THIRTY
TWO WILL EXPAND OVER FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OF FEDERAL RENT
ASSISTANCE. TO EXTEND THE
STATEWIDE ELECTION MORATORIUM
THROUGH SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. INCREASE
BRETT REIMBURSEMENT 21100% FOR
BOTH RENT IN ARREARS AND
PROSPECTIVE PAYMENTS. IT'S A
PATHWAY FOR TENANTS TO RECEIVE
DIRECT RENT PAYMENTS IN THE
EVENT ALANLAR DOES NOT
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM. IN
ADDITION TO THE REVAMPED AND
READ ROBUST CASH ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM OFFERED THROUGH AB
EIGHT THIRTY TWO THE BILL ALSO
CREATES A NEW COURT PROCESS TO
ENSURE TENANTS ARE PROTECTED
AFTER THE EVICTION MORATORIUM
IS LIFTED AT THE END OF
SEPTEMBER. AND I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
ALL BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT IS
WHAT HAPPENS. WHEN THE MARK
MORATORIUM ENDS. SHOULD ALIGN
OR PURSUE AN UNLAWFUL DETAINER
ACTION AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO NOW
REQUIRES THAT LANDLORDS PROVIDE
EVIDENCE TO THE COURT. THAT
THEY ATTEMPTED TO SECURE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THE NON PAYMENT
OF RENT LET'S DO THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT TENANTS ARE NOT
EVICTED BECAUSE THE LANDLORD
FOR. FAILED TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM AND IT KEEPS
EVERYBODY HONEST IN THE PROCESS.
FOURTEEN MONTHS HAVE PASSED
SINCE THE GOVERNOR DECLARED A
STATE OF EMERGENCY. AND MANY
HAVE SUFFERED TERRIBLE LOSS OF
FAMILY AND LOVED ONES BECAUSE
OF THIS VIRUS. MANY MORE WERE
PUT OUT OF WORK THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN IN
PARTICULAR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
WHO DISPROPORTIONATELY WORK IN
THE SERVICE INDUSTRY. AND FELT
THE HARSHEST IMPACT OF THE
CORONA VIRUS DESPITE THE
NECESSARY HARDSHIP THE STATE.
SHUT DOWN BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
HAS COME BACK JUST AS STRONG IF
NOT STRONGER THAN BEFORE. OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT IS NOW THE LOWEST
IT'S BEEN SINCE THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN IS GETTING CLOSER TO PRE
FUND DIFERENT LEVELS EVERY
MONTH AND OUR STATE REVENUES
ARE HIGHER THAN ANYONE COULD
EVER PROJECTED. I'M CONFIDENT
THAT AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO IS A
MEASURED APPROACH THAT PROTECTS
VULNERABLE TENANTS. HELPS
LANDLORDS RECOVERED FROM
TREMENDOUS LOSSES AND WILL
SERVE AS A SAFETY NET
NECESSARY. TO MOVE IT TO THE
OTHER SIDE OF THIS HISTORIC
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECT FOR YOUR I. BOATS HERE
I BOUGHT TODAY THANK YOU CENTER
CABALLERO SENATOR BATES FOR
WHAT PURPOSE YOU RISE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I DO HAVE
FRIENDLY AMENDMENTS AT THE
DESK. VERY GOOD MOMENTUM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ
THE AMENDMENTS. AMENDMENTS BY
SENATOR BATES SAT ONE. THANK
YOU OUR MEMBERS THE AMENDMENTS
ARE QUITE SIMPLE HOURS MAY I
READ NOTWITHSTANDING ANY OTHER
LAW A TENANT SHALL NOT BE
ELIGIBLE FOR RENTAL RELIEF
UNDER THIS CHAPTER IF THE
TENANT DID NOT FILE A CLAIM FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BETWEEN
MARCH FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY AND
JUNE FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. NOTWITHSTANDING ANY OTHER
LAW A TENANT WHO DID NOT FILE A
CLAIM FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BETWEEN MARCH FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY AND JUNE FIFTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SHALL MAKE
PAYMENT IN FULL OF ALL PAST DUE
RENT TO THEIR LANDLORD WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS OF THE EFFECTIVE
DATE OF THIS FACT. MEMBERS
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS HAVE
BEEN SEVERELY IMPACTED BY KOBE
JUST LIKE EVERYONE ELSE RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS MUST STILL PAY
THEIR PROPERTY TAXES THEIR
OPERATIONAL COSTS AND SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILIES FROM RENTAL
INCOME AND I THINK WE ALL KNOW
MANY OF OUR SENIORS THAT IS HOW
THEY ARE SURVIVING THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM AND ITS EXTENSION
HAVE NOT WORKED THE MONEY HAS
NOT GONE OUT. RATHER IT HAS
CREATED AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
ONGOING ABUSES FROM RANCHERS
WHO HAVE NOT BEEN FINANCIALLY
AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMIC THERE
ARE RENTERS WHO CAN'T PAY THE
RENT BUT I'VE USED THE STATE'S
POLICIES TO AVOID PAYING RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS HAVE PATIENTLY
WAITED UNTILJUNE THIRTIETH TO
RECEIVE THOSE RENT PAYMENTS
THERE'S NO REASON THEY SHOULD
HAVE TO WAIT ANY LONGER. THESE
AMENDMENTS WOULD LIMIT THIS
NEXT EXTENSION ONLY TO THOSE
RENTERS WHO HAVE FILED
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS DURING COLD
DEAD FROM THE DATE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S EMERGENCY TO JUNE
FIFTEENTH WHEN CALIFORNIA RE
OPENED THOSE WHO HAVE NOT FILED
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PAY THEIR PAST DUE
RENT WITHIN THOSE THIRTY DAYS
THE AMENDMENTS ALLOW FOR THOSE
RENTERS WHO HAVE BEEN
FINANCIALLY IMPACTED TO GET THE
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED. EVERYONE
ELSE NEEDS TO PAY THE RANSOM.
RENTAL PROPERTY- OWNERS HAVE
MORE IN TH WEIGHT OF THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
ACTIONS. QUITE LONG ENOUGH I
ASK FOR YOUR I. VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES SAID HER TO WORK FOR A
PURPOSE YOU RISE THANK YOU TO
MAKE MOTIONS RELATING THEM IT'S
ON THE TABLE MADAM. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS ASKING TOO
LATE THE MOST- THE AMENDMENTS
ON THE TABLE. MADAM SECRETARY
IS ASKING FOR AN IPHONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA. I AT KINS HI
BASED. BAIT NO BACKER. I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I BY ADAM
HI CORTEZ C. FIVE DALLY NO DODD.
HI THERE ARE SO HI A COMMON HI
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG. I WISH SO HI HER
TADO HI JONES. CAN LONGER FIVE
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MON HI
WHERE HI MELINDA'S NO MEN I
NEWMAN I NELSON NO BUT SHOW UP
BOTH NO TAN HI FORTUNE TINO I.
ROSS I RUBIO. HI SKINNER I
STERN HI AMBERG HI BY CAL SKI
FIVE WINNER I WILL NO PLEASE
CALL THE HELP THE MEMBER. JONES
NO. FIVE THIRTY ONE KNOWS NINE
THE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN LAID
ON THE TABLE MEMBERS WE WILL
NOW RETURN TO THE BILL IN CHIEF
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE ON THE BILL CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SORRY NEEDS TO
SIT IN THIS CHAIR FOR
COMMITTEE. AND NOTHING AND
FLOWER BEDS A QUESTION THE
AUTHOR IF POSSIBLE. IN A CAREER
WE TAKE A QUESTION ABSOLUTELY
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
THROUGH THE CHAIR- R. ET DE
PAYMENTS- CALCULATED INTO THE
FORMULA IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
THESE BENEFITS. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS NO. THANK YOU-
IF THE LANDLORDS PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROGRAM- DO THE LANDLORDS
GET THE DIRECT PAYMENTS FROM
THE STATE OR THE AGENCY PAYING
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF THE-
PERSON IT'S RENTING THE
PROPERTY OR DOES IT GO TO THE
INDIVIDUAL AND THEN TO THE
LANDLORD. SO UNDER THIS BILL-
THE LANDLORD WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THE PAYMENTS IF THEY'RE
IF THEY'RE PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROGRAM. THAT HAS BEEN THE CASE
IN THE PRIOR BILL- AND SO THAT
PRACTICE WILL CONTINUE HOWEVER
IF THE LANDLORD DECLINES AND
RENT IS FOLLOWED. NINE A BIG
LANDLORD DECLINES TO
PARTICIPATE AND THEY'RE STILL
MONEY THAT'S OWED BY THE TENANT
THE TENANT CAN RECEIVE THE
MONEY. AND THEN I HAVE TWO MORE
QUESTIONS I APOLOGIZE IF THE
PAYMENTS ARE MADE TO THE
LANDLORD IS IT A PERCENTAGE OF
THE RENT DO YOU OR IS IT 1100%
COVERAGE OF THE RENT. IT IS
1100% COVERAGE OF THE RENT. AND
I GUESS THE FINAL QUESTION I
HAVE IS THAT- THERE'S- DOLLARS
IN THIS PACKAGE FROM THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. TO GO
BACK AND PAY. PAST DEBTS. THAT
THE LANDLORD IS OWED- PRIOR TO
THEM BEING ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN A PROGRAM SO. I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS IF A LANDLORD IN
ROLES TODAY. WHEN THIS BILL
PASSES AND THEY HAVE A TENANT
WHO HASN'T PAID BILLS FOR SIX
MONTHS. WITH THIS AMERICAN
RESCUE FUNDS ALLOW THE LANDLORD
TO GO BACK AND PARTICIPATE IN
THAT WINTER RECOVERY. YES IT
DOES THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU
CENTER GROUP CENTER TORONTO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AS
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL
I URGE SUPPORT TODAY ALMOST 80%
OF MY CONSTITUENTS ARE RENTERS
MORE THAN ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE
STATE MANY OF THE FAMILIES WERE
ALREADY LIVING ON THE EDGE OF
ECONOMIC EVICTION BEFORE THE
INSTABILITY OF THIS PAST YEAR.
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE
OVERWHELMING NEED FOR RENTAL
ASSISTANCE IN LOS ANGELES
DURING THE OPEN APPLICATION
PERIOD FOR RENT ASSISTANCE.
MORE THAN SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
TENANTS SUBMITTED APPLICATIONS
ALONG WITH MORE THAN FORTY
THREE THOUSAND LANDLORDS IT'S
ADDED UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
RENTAL ARREARS THE EXTENSION OF
THE VACATION MORATORIUM WILL
KEEP FAMILIES IN THEIR HOMES
WHILE THEY ACCESS NEEDED
ASSISTANCE WILL HELP MAKE SURE
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE STABLE AS
WE CONTINUE TO RECOVER AND HEAL
FROM THIS DEVASTATING CRISIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
DRAWS- SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT AS A PRINCIPAL
CO AUTHOR OF THE V. THIRTY TWO-
ALSO REPRESENT- COMMUNITY THAT-
WITH AN ENORMOUS NUMBER OF
RENTERS HI I AM A VERY
EXPENSIVE COMMUNITY WHO ARE
HANGING ON BY THEIR FINGERNAILS
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND ARE
TRULY HANG ON BY THEIR
FINGERNAILS- TODAY- WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE FIRST AND FOREMOST-
AS WE COME OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC. THAT WE KEEP PEOPLE
STABLE IN THEIR HOMES I THINK
THAT THERE IS A TENDENCY NOW
BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE ALL
EXUBERANCE- ABOUT THE VACCINE
ABOUT THE REOPENING- ABOUT ALL
THE PROGRESS WE'RE MAKING IN
COMING UT OF THE PANDEMIC. BUT
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND AND
ALWAYS REMEMBER THAT THE CURVE
IN NINETEEN TEN THE NEXT HAS
LEFT DEEP ECONOMIC SCARS ON THE
STATE THOSE CARS HAVE NOT
HEALED SO MANY PEOPLE ARE NOT
BACK AT WORK SO MANY PEOPLE AS
WE KNOW TRAGICALLY STILL HAVE
NOT RECEIVED THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. A LIVING OF THEIR
CREDIT CARDS. THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE LOST A HEAD OF
HOUSEHOLD WHO PASSED AWAY. TO
THE COVE IT OR OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS THIS PANDEMIC HAS
BROUGHT SUCH DEEP LASTING
STRESS. THE ECONOMIC STRUCTURE
OF THE STATE IT IS GOING TO
TAKE US TIME TO RECOVER. AND
THE LAST THING THAT WE NEED. TO
COME OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC. IS
TO HAVE WAVES OF AFFECTIONS AND
WAVES OF EVEN MORE HOMELESSNESS.
AND WE HAVE ALREADY DONE WILL.
EMPTY OUR ABILITY. TO RECOVER.
I WANT TO BE FREE THIS STILL
NOT. THIS WAS OVER OF GIVEN TO-
THERE ARE GOOD THINGS THIS BILL
THE EXTENT OF THE MORE. THE
INCREASE TO A 100% THE FACT
THAT WE'RE NOW ALLOWING TENANTS
TO APPLY DIRECTLY AND THEY
DON'T JUST HAVE TO. RELY ON
THEIR LANDLORD TO APPLY THE
FACT THAT WE NOW HAVE STRONGER
INCENTIVES FOR LANDLORDS TO
PARTICIPATE BECAUSE THEY MAY
NOT GET AN INFECTION IF THEY
DECLINED TO PARTICIPATE IN
GETTING A 100% OF THE RENT.
PAID THAT IS ALL GOOD WE WILL
ALLOW MORE TENANTS- TO AVOID
RENT THAT MORE LANDLORDS WILL
GET PAID ALL OF THEIR
BACKGROUND. I'M NOT A FAN OF
SOME PIECES OF THIS LIKE THE-
THE LONG PREEMPTION- BYE YOU
KNOW THIS WAS A RESULT OF
NEGOTIATION AND GIVE AND TAKE.
AND I THINK IT IS A GOOD
PRODUCT WHAT I DO JUST WANT TO
CLOSE BY SAYING WE HAVE TO.
HOLD THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
AGENCIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR MAKING
THIS A MUCH EASIER PROCESS FOR
PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY APPLY FOR
THE MONEY IT SHOULDN'T TAKE A
THIRTY TWO PAGE APPLICATION.
RESIDENTS TAKE HAVING TO CALL
ON THE PHONE LINES WERE YOU
CAN'T GET ANYONE ON THE PHONE
WE MUST MOVE THIS MONEY OUT TO
THE PEOPLE BOTH LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS WHO NEED IT- WE HAVE TO
DO BETTER IN THAT REGARD. BUT
THIS IS A CRITICAL STEP
WEDNESDAY IS RIGHT UPON US AND
I ASKED. FOR AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR WIENER CENTRE
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MA'AM FOR I
TOO STAND SUPPORT A AV. EIGHT
THIRTY TWO AND I TO HAVE SOME
THOUGHTS ABOUT AND CONCERNS
ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION. I'M
PLEASED THAT THIS BILL WILL
PREVENT MORE CALIFORNIA FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS BUT CURRENTLY
THERE'S OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND. CALIFORNIANS YOU'RE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITH
THE MAJORITY OF THOSE BEING
AFRICAN AMERICAN. FOR EXAMPLE
AFTER AMERICAN PEOPLE MAKE UP
80% OF LA COUNTY BUT OVER 40%
OF THE HOMELESSNESS WE SHOULD
ALL BE CONCERNED ABOUT THESE
NUMBERS IN THOSE- PEOPLE WHO
ARE BEING IMPACTED. I
APPRECIATE THE DIVISIONAL TIME
IN THIS EXTENSION FOR MANY WHO
NEED THIS RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
WHO HAVE YET TO RECEIVE IT
HOWEVER SOME TENETS OF SMALL
LANDLORDS. HAVE STATED AND
COMPLAINED ABOUT THE DIFFICULTY
ENROLLING IN THIS PROGRAM JUST
THIS WEEKEND WHEN I WAS DOING A
TOUR OF THE SOAP BY STADIUM IN
INGLEWOOD I WAS APPROACHED BY.
THREE LANDLORDS WHO COMPLAINED
ABOUT HALL CUMBERSOME AND
DIFFICULT THIS WAS IN THE FACT
THAT THEY HIT ONE HIT FIVE
TENDED TO MADE NO EFFORT. TO
PAY RENT IN THE LAST EIGHT
MONTHS DESPITE ALL THE PROGRAMS
THAT WERE MADE AVAILABLE FORM
IN THE YET TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
IT SO IT IS A CUMBERSOME
PROCESS. AND LANDLORDS ARE
FRUSTRATED JUST AS WELL AS
TENANTS ARE FEARFUL OF BEING
DISPLACED. I APPRECIATE THE
CONTINUED PROGRESS ON MAKING.
ASSISTANCE EASIER TO ACCESS AND
I HOPE WE CAN AND MORE CAN BE
DONE TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
AS WE GO FORWARD. THE REDUCED
IMPACT ON PEOPLE- I ALSO HAVE
EXPRESSED CONCERNS THAT THIS
RULE SINCE ITS PROGRAM MIGHT
NOT BE REACHING ALL THE
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY THOSE
AT THE COMMUNITIES ARE STATED-
NOW REACH BY THE STATE HAS NOT
ACHIEVED A MEANINGFUL
CONNECTIONS. TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT THE
MOST PARTICULARLY BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES- TODAY'S
BUDGET ACTION WILL PROVIDE
FUNDING TO ETHNIC MEDIA VIA THE
STATE LIBRARY BUT I DON'T
THINK. THAT'S THE REAL ANSWER.
IT'S A GOOD MEASURE AND IT
COULD COMPLEMENT OUR EFFORTS
BUT MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
ADDRESS THE DISPARITIES THAT
EXIST NOT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
RADFORD SENATOR MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR
THE AUTHOR. SENECA WHERE WE
TAKE A QUESTION OR TWO YES THEY
WERE PLEASE PROCEED- THANK YOU
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND CLEARLY THAT IN
ORDER FOR REIMBURSEMENT TO TAKE
PLACE THE TENANT AND THE
LANDLORD MUST BOTH APPLY FOR
THE PROGRAM IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY AND SET
THE TENANT CHOOSES NOT TO.
APPLY THEN THE LANDLORD DOES
NOT GET ANY TYPE OF
REIMBURSEMENTS ARE CORRECT THAT
IS CORRECT. OKAY- SO THE SECOND
QUESTION IS- OVER THE LAST YEAR
IT'S I THINK THE ESTIMATE WAS
SIX UNDER NINETEEN MILLION WAS
REQUESTED- IN REIMBURSEMENT
FUNDS AND OF THAT SIX HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILLION THE STATE HAS
PAID OUT. 80% OF THOSE FUNDS SO
WHAT IS IN THIS BILL TO INSURE
THAT. ALL OF THE MONEY IS PAID
OUT IN THIS I MEAN 8% IS.
EMBARRASSING 8% OVER THE LAST
YEAR HAS BEEN PAID OUT SO. HOW
DO WE ENSURE THAT THAT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THIS-
EXTENSION OF THE MORATORIUM AN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS THINKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THE 8%
REPRESENTS OR THE PERCENTAGE-
AND I DON'T I CREEK QUITE
FRANKLY TO REMEMBER C. 8%
REPRESENTS THIS THE PART THAT
THE STATE IS ADMINISTERING
APART FROM THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION. THE BIG CITIES
AND THE BIGGER COUNTIES WERE
GIVEN A DIRECT ALLOCATION FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THAT
DATA WE DON'T IS NOT INCLUDED
IN THAT PERCENTAGE THAT YOU
QUOTED AND SO- THEY ARE DOING
THEIR OWN PROGRAMS. I'M A
COUPLE OF THE COUNTIES HAVE AND
MAYBE MORE THAN A COUPLE HAVE
ELECTED TO PAY UP TO A HUNDRED
PERCENT. OF THE PAST DUE RENT
AND- AND SO THERE'S ARE A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT BUT AS AS
FAR AS THE STATE PROCESS HAS
GONE- THE NUMBERS ARE ARE ARE
FAIRLY FAIRLY SMALL AND SO
WE'VE BEEN VERY CRITICAL. OF
THE ADMINISTRATION AND WE'VE
ASKED THAT THEY EXPEDITE THEIR
THEIR APPLICATION PROCESS THAT
IT BECOME MUCH SIMPLER. AND
THAT THEY ENGAGE THE LANDLORD
COMMUNITY SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT THE LANDLORDS ARE
PARTICIPATING AS WELL BECAUSE
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT'S PART
OF BEING PART OF THE ISSUE.
WITH WITH THE ALLOCATION OF-
ALLOCATING THE FUNDS SO WE'VE
GOT A COMMITMENT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT- THE
PROCESS IS GOING TO MOVE FASTER
AND THAT PART THAT WE CAN
CONTROL WILL BE- THE PART THAT
WE SEE THE DATA ON. THANK YOU
SENATOR CABALLERO. THE CENTER
MALL IS THANK YOU SO MUCH JUST
A FOLLOW UP SO IT'S- ALMOST
JULY AND THIS IS GOING TO
EXTEND IT AND THROUGH END OF
SEPTEMBER. RIGHT THE MORATORIUM
MAKES IS EXTENDED TO SEPTEMBER
NOT THE ALLOCATION OF THE
RESOURCES WE HAVE THE
ALLOCATION OF THE RESOURCES FOR
MORE THAN THAT RIGHT SO. IF WE
ALL RECOGNIZE THAT UP SOME
CHANGES NEED TO BE MADE TO THE
PROCESS TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
ALL PARTIES INVOLVED TO APPLY
AND GET THEIR FUNDS REIMBURSED.
THAT'S A VERY SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME FOR- YOU KNOW THESE
DEPARTMENTS TO RE WORK THESE
FORMS TO GET IPUT FROM.
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS AND THEN.
GET THAT RE WORKED APPLICATION
OUT TO THOSE WHO I MEAN IS THAT
REALISTIC. SO IT'S IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS CRITICISM
OF THE PROCESS HAS BEEN- HAS
BEEN EXPRESSED FOR SOME TIME
BEEN VERY CLEAR THAT THE MONEY
IS WASN'T GETTING OUT THE DOOR
FAST ENOUGH AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ALREADY
WORKED ON THE ON THE REDESIGN
OF THE APPLICATION PROCESS AND
THAT IT IT IS DONE IF IT'S NOT
CLOSE TO BEING DONE SO IT'S MY
EXPECTATION. THAT ONCE THIS
BILL IS PASSED WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE ACTIVELY MOVING THIS
QUICKLY- RATHER THAN WAITING%
UNTIL AUGUST IS BECAUSE WE
REALLY WANT TO GET THE MONEY
OUT WANT TO GET PEOPLE- IT'D
MAKE AT NU OP ART TO MAKE AN
APPLICATION AND TO- MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING RESOURCES
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR
MELINDA'S SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MINUTE
PRESENT I WANT TO. ADD A COUPLE
OF POINTS GIVEN THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT WAS RAISED FIRST OF ALL.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID THE
SECRETARY OF TREASURY HAS
CHANGED THE GUIDANCE WITH
RESPECT TO HOW THIS PROGRAM
OPERATED BEFORE. AND HOW IT
OPERATES NOW. THERE'S AN
ABILITY TO SELF CERTIFY WHICH
HAS MADE IT A LOT EASIER FOR
THE MECHANICS OF THE PROGRAM TO
OPERATE SECOND. THIS IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT ASPECT UNDER THE
PREVIOUS RULES THE LANDLORD HAD
TO ACCEPT EIGHTY PERCENT. THE
GENERAL PRINCIPLE OF LAW IS
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE A CONTRACT
YOU CAN'T IMPAIR THE CONTRACT
AND ASK THE LANDLORD TO ACCEPT
LESS THAN. A HUNDRED CENTS ON
THE DOLLAR UNLESS YOU
INCENTIVIZE AND THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE TAX INCENTIVES AND ALL
SORTS OF PROGRAMS TO
INCENTIVIZE CERTAIN LEVELS OF
BEHAVIOR. BUT WHEN YOU PAY A
100% WHICH IS NOW THE CONTENT
OF THIS MEASURE THE ENTIRE
MECHANISM OF THE PROCESS
CHANGES. BECAUSE IF I GO TO-
SAY THE PRO TEM AND I SAY
LISTENABLE SHORT OF MONEY CAN
YOU LEND ME. MY SCRATCH FOR
RENT THIS MONTH SHE WANTED TO
MEET THE LANDLORD DOESN'T KNOW
THAT THE PRO TEM LET ME THE-MONEY THE LANDLORD WAS PAY
DOESN'T MATTER WHERE YOU GET
THE MONEY FROM. CHANGE THE
RULES DRAMATICALLY AND ALLOWS
THE PROGRAM TO BE STREAMLINED
WHICH- HAS THE AUTHOR HAS
INDICATED IS ALREADY HAPPENING
WITH RESPECT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS IN IN
THAT REGARD SO. WITH THE
TENANTS RIGHT TO APPLYING. WITH
THE 100% WHICH FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGES THE PROCESS GOING
FORWARD. WITH THE DIFFERENT
GUIDANCE PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF TREASURY IN THE
UNITED STATES UNDERSECRETARY
ELLEN. IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE THE CONSTRAINTS THAT WE
HAVE IS A LEGISLATURE. IN
MOVING FORWARD AND THOSE
MEASURES HAVE BEEN INFORMED IN
WHAT IS BEFORE YOU TODAY. AND
FOR THOSE REASONS I ASKED FOR A
NOVEL. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF
COURSE THE AUTHOR. SENATE
CAREER WOULD TAKE A QUESTION
SURE PLEASE DON'T FEED. F. AS
WITH A STATEMENT FIRST OF ALL
WE'RE ALL IN AGREEMENT THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE. NOT HAD THE
ABILITY TO PAY THE RENT OR THE
PERSON THAT IS RENTING NEEDS TO
BE MADE WHOLE. AND WITH THAT
BEING SAID WE'VE HEARD ON THE
FLOOR TODAY ABOUT STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE CAN DO IT IN A QUICK
MANNER SO WITH THAT BEING SAID
ARE THERE ANY SAFEGUARDS IN
THIS BILL THAT WE ARE MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT GETTING
FRAUD WE SAW. WITH THE D. D.
THAT WE TOOK THE EMPLOYER OUT
OF THE EQUATION WE SAW LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FRAUD SO WHEN
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION IN
THIS CIRCUMSTANCE. IS THERE
FRAUD PROTECTION IN THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION- YES AND
THAT THAT WAS PART OF THE
REASON THAT. THE APPLICATION
PROCESS WAS FAIRLY EXTENSIVE
BECAUSE THE- THE- GOAL WAS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WORD WERE
PROTECTED NETWORK WERE NOT
SUBJECT TO FRAUD AND THAT
PEOPLE ARE GETTING CHECKS THAT
SHOULDN'T GET THE CHECKS- BUT
BUT- AS- THE SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES SAID WE'VE COME UP WITH
A BETTER WAY TO BE ABLE TO SELF
CERTIFY AND TO BE ABLE TO- MAKE
SURE THAT THE MONEY IS GOING TO
PAY THE LANDLORD. AT TO PAY
DOWN RENT AND SO- YES THERE
THERE ARE THERE ARE PROCESSES
IN IN THAT IN THERE ARE
PROCESSES AND WE'RE REQUIRED TO
FOLLOW THIS PROCESS. SO WE'RE
ABLE TO TRACK THEN- AT A LATER
DATE WILL BE ABLE TO TRACK TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE WAS THE
ABILITY THAT THEY- THEY WENT TO
THE PEOPLE THAT SHOULD GO TO.
ANOTHER PEOPLE SHOULD GO TO
YES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR HOLLINGS CENTER
MORICHES. QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR IF I MAY SET A CAREER WE
TAKE A QUESTION I YES I WILL
AND THEN FROM THIS POINT ON
I'LL DO IT IN MY CLOTHES ARE
VERY GOOD CENTER MORICHES THANK
YOU- CAN YOU EXPLAIN A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT SELF
CERTIFICATION BECAUSE I KNOW WE
DEALT WITH THIS IN THE- THE
PREVIOUS ITERATIONS AND IN
TWENTY TWENTY. WE WERE LOOKING
FOR SOME SORT OF VERIFICATION
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL DID IN FACT
LOSE THEIR JOB- AND WAS NOT IN
A FINANCIAL CAPACITY TO PAY THE
RENT YOU TALK JUST A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT SELF CERTIFICATION. YOUR
SELF AT THE STATION. GOOD
QUESTION. I DON'T HAVE THE
MECHANISM IN FRONT OF ME TELL
YOU THE TRUTH- WE TALKED ABOUT
IT AS PART OF THE BILL WHICH
WAS TO EXPEDITE THE PROCESS A
LITTLE BIT WHICH WOULD GET US
AWAY FROM THE THIRTY TWO PAGE
DOCUMENT THAT THAT WAS
REQUIRED- BUT I HAVE TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU I JUST DON'T
REMEMBER RIGHT OFF THE TOP OF
MY HEAD TELL YOU THE TRUTH.
WOULD IT BE APPROPRIATE MANNER
PRESIDENT TO ASK ANY OTHER
REPRESENTATIVE IN THE ROOM IF.
THERE COULD BE AN EXPLANATION
ON THAT. IF I HAVE MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM LOS ANGELES AND MAY
BE ABLE TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
OKAY ONE MOMENT CENTER BARGES.
CENTERS FOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE QUESTION SURE WE
HAVE IT YOU PLEASE PROCEED JUST
YOU KNOW JUST LIKE AS YOU KNOW
AS A MEMBER OF THE BAR THAT YOU
SIMPLY SIGN A DECLARATION OF
THE PENALTY OF PERJURY WE DO
THIS ALL THE TIME IN
PROCEEDINGS BEFORE THE COURT.
WHERE WE SIGNED A DECLARATION
WE OUTLINED THE FAX THE
DECLARATIONS EVERY SO WHEN YOU
SIMPLY FILE AN UNLAWFUL
DETAINER ACTION IT'S A JUDICIAL
COUNCIL FORM WITH A BUNCH OF
BOXES THE END YOU SIGN ON TO A
PENALTY OF PERJURY THAT
SUFFICIENT AND THERE'S
CONSEQUENCES FOR LYING ON THE
ON A GOVERNMENT DOCUMENT AND
THAT'S SO THAT IS CERTAINLY HOW
IT'S HOW IT'S BEEN DONE ALL
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AND HOW
IT'S DONE EVERY SINGLE UNLAWFUL
DETAINER PROCEEDINGS IN TERMS
OF WHAT EVIDENCE BEFORE COURT.
AND THAT'S HOW IT GETS DONE
THIS CONSEQUENCES FOR NOT
TELLING THE TRUTH BUT THERE'S A
REAL PROCESS IN PLACE THAT WE
USE TO EVERY JUDICIAL
PROCEEDING AND WOULD SIMPLY BE
APPLIED HERE AND. CERTAINLY
WITH PINTS OF CERTIFICATIONS
REGARD. THINKCENTRE YOUR-
CENTER PORCHES I THINK THAT'S
FINE. THANK YOU YES. SENATOR
ATKINS MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND LET ME SAY
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR- FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO WALK THROUGH
SO MUCH OF THESE DETAILS WE ARE
FOLLOWING FEDERAL GUIDELINES
WHICH REQUIRE SELF ATTESTATION
OR SELF CERTIFICATION AND IN
ADDITION AS THE AUTHOR HAVE
SAID WE ARE WORKING BETWEEN AND
EXTENSIVELY LONG DOCUMENT THAT
PRECLUDED SOME PEOPLE FROM
FEELING LIKE THEY COULD
ACTUALLY PARTICIPATE IN A
PROGRAM TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE RESOURCES PROVIDED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. SO THERE IS A
BALANCING ACT BETWEEN MAKING
SURE THAT THE FORM IS SUCH THAT
PEOPLE USE IT- THAT THE
LANDLORDS ARE GONE AND THEN
ALSO BE ABLE TO ACCESS THE
FUNDS. AND AT THE SAME TIME TRY
TO MAKE SURE WE'VE GOT THE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE TO AVOID
ANOTHER SITUATION WHERE WE ARE
TRYING TO HELP. RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA AND MEET ALL OF-THESE DIFFERENT CONDITIONS SO
WHEN WE SAID ONCE BEFORE THAT
WE WERE GOING TO HAVE WORK TO
DO WE KNEW THAT WE WERE GOING
TO HAVE CONTINUED WORK TO DO TO
GET DOLLARS IN THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO NEEDED THE
RESOURCES. SO THAT THEY CAN
KEEP A ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS SO
THAT LANDLORDS COULD BE PAID.
SMALL LANDLORDS- AND SO I
THINK. I UNDERSTAND THE NATURE
OF THE QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS
BECAUSE CLEARLY WE WANT THESE
DOLLARS- THAT WE'RE GETTING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
BE USED IN THE BEST MANNER
POSSIBLE TO TAKE CARE OF THE
NEEDS. AND I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO
WORK HERE BECAUSE SHOULD THIS
PROGRAM STILL BE CUMBERSOME OR
WERE NOT ABLE TO GET THE
DOLLARS OUT IN A TIMELY
FASHION. WE'VE COMMITTED AS
PART OF THE DISCUSSION WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND A AND
THE- ASSEMBLY. THAT WE MAY HAVE
MORE WORK TO DO IN FACT THE
MAJORITY LEADER HAS
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR OTHER
IMPROVEMENTS ALONG THE WAY- BUT
IN THAT. EXPEDIENCY TO MAKE
SURE WE DON'T MISS A DEADLINE-
THAT IS UPON US AND THAT PEOPLE
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE NO
RESOURCES AND THEN THINK
THERE'S NO PROGRAMMING OR
FURTHER CONFUSED. I APPLAUD THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE AND I
HOPE THAT THAT IS HELPFUL TO
SOME DEGREE IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SARAH PALMER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THE QUESTIONS IN
THE COMMENTS ARE MUCH
APPRECIATED- THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT THIS BILL GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY. THEY HAVE THE TIME
WE NEED TO RECOVER- THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT WE NEED TO HELP
TENANTS WE DO NOT WANT THEM TO
END UP HOMELESS AND ON THE
STREETS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T THEY
COULDN'T PAY A DEBT. THAT WAS
DUE AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE HELPING LANDLORDS AS WELL
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN PATIENT
MANY OF THEM HAVE MISSED THEIR
OWN PAYMENTS FOR THEIR TAXES.
AND THEY DESPERATELY NEED
RESOURCES IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE
HOUSING THAT IS MUCH NEEDED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- AS I
INDICATED THE ADMINISTRATION IS
HAS THE COMMITMENT TO GET THESE
FUNDS OUT QUICKLY AND TO DO IT
IN A- IN A- RESPONSIBLE MANNER
AND I BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL DO
THAT BUT WE WILL HAVE TO. WATCH
AND MAKE SURE THA THIS ALL
WORKS OUT WELL- AND WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY THANK YOU SENATOR
CAFIERO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I AT KINS I BASE. I
BECKER HI FOR JUST. BRADFORD
WELL I HAVE I EVER HI COURTESY
HI DALLY. DODD HI THERE AWESOME
HI AIKMAN I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
FIVE GROVE FIVE HURTS BERG HI
WITH SO. HI TIDO HI JONES.
CATALOGUER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I
LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN FIVE NEWMAN I
NELSON. BUT SHOW A BOKE. PAN HI
FORCING TINA. HI ROSS HI RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER I STERN HI AMBERG
I Y. CASKEY I WINNER I WILL HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS DALLY. JONES MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN A SHOW ABOUT. BY THIRTY
FOUR NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY
FIVE THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS YOU
RECEIVED AN ADDITIONAL
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE ON YOUR DESK
IN THE SENATE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
NUMBER TWO IF YOU'LL PLEASE
TURN TO FILE ITEM ONE OH THREE
SB ONE FORTY SEVEN. MADAM
SENATOR SKINNER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ONE
FORTY SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT
RELATING TO THE STATE BUDGET
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BELL.
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS FARM.
S. B. ONE FORTY SEVEN IS THE
CURRENT YEAR SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATIONS BILL BENNETT
APPROPRIATE SEVENTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION IN GENERAL FUNDS TO AN
ADDRESS UNANTICIPATED COSTS
THAT WERE INCURRED DURING THE
CURRENT BUDGET YEAR AND
SPECIFICALLY AT SEVENTEEN POINT
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN POINT ONE
NINE WHICH WILL BE ALLOCATED TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
TO COMPLY WITH A COURT ORDER.
THAT FOUND THE DEPARTMENT
VIOLATED THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT SEVEN THE
COURT REQUIRES YOU TO SHARE OUR
TO INSTALL SECURITY CAMERAS AND
OTHER AT. CAPTIONS AND SECOND
THE BILL APPROPRIATES TEN
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED TO
REIMBURSE MARIPOSA COUNTY FOR
THE COST OF STORING EVIDENCE
AND FILES IN THE CASE OF THE
PEOPLE VERSUS KERRY SKINNER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVALS.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
MEMBERS THERE ANY QUESTIONS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA I AT KINS I
BASE. BACKER FIVE FOUR JUST HI
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
COURTESY. FIVE DALLY HI TODD.
FIVE THERE ARE SO HI ADNAN I
GLAZER FIVE DOLLARS HI GROSS HI
HURTS FOR. I WAS SO HYPER TIDO
HI JONES. I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON. HI
THE CHOIR HI MELINDA'S FIVE MEN
I NEWMAN I NIELSEN HI A CHILL
OF BOCA. I CAN I FORTUNE TINO I
ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER I
STERN HI AMBERG I Y. CASTING I
WINNER. I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE OFFICE AND MEMBER. BATES HI.
HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MEMBER THROWING TO
FILE ITEM ONE OH FOUR SP ONE
FIFTY TWO MEN SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY TWO
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTIONS AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT. A LITTLE
DIFFERENT ORDER THAN I WAS
EXPECTING. YOUR GOOD.
MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. THAT'S
B. ONE FIFTY TWO IS THE
ELECTIONS TRAILER BILL THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SENT A
LETTER TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND PROVIDED
AN ESTIMATE OF THE COSTS TO
ADMINISTER THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE GIVEN A TORY ELECTION WHICH
IS TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
MILLION THIS AMOUNT WAS
APPROPRIATED IN THE BUDGET BILL
THAT WE PASSED EARLIER THIS
MONTH. THIS BILL REQUIRES
COUNTIES TO CONDUCT AN ALL MAIL
BALLOT ELECTION AS SPECIFIED
THIS BILL ALSO CLARIFIES THAT
THE SECRETARY OF STATE CAN
CERTIFIED THE SIGNATURES ONCE
THE LEGISLATURE HAS
APPROPRIATED THE FUNDS TO
DETERMINES IS REASONABLY
NECESSARY TO CONDUCT THE RECALL
ELECTION AND THE DESIGNATED
FUNDS FOR THIS PURPOSE WITHOUT
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SENATOR DOLLY. THE
MEN PRESENT MEMBERS I RISE- AN
OPPOSITION THERE'S PART OF THIS
BILL I REALLY LIKE I THINK WE
SHOULD BE COMMENTATING COUNTIES
FOR SPECIAL ELECTIONS AS THE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION BUT
THERE'S THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. IN THIS- IN THIS
BUDGET BILL THAT IS GOING TO GO
TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE AND I
ASKED- THIS MORNING DURING OUR
BUDGET HEARING. IF THOSE
CONTRACTS WE'RE GOING TO BE.
THAT TOO N. B. OUT FOR BID AND-
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO GET BACK TO
ME- THEY COULDN'T ANSWER THAT
QUESTION AND SO WE DON'T KNOW
HOW THIS CONTRACT FOR THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IS
GOING TO GO TO THE SECRETARY
STATE IS GONNA BE IMPLEMENTED
SO FOR THOSE REASONS I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
HOLLINGS SENATOR WILK. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
ACTUALLY FOR THAT THE SAME
REASON OUT AT THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS SEVENTY MILLION
OF THAT. CAN BE ON A NO BID
CONTRACT. AND FOR ME THIS LIKE
DEJA VU ALL OVER AGAIN. IF YOU
RECALL LAST ELECTION CYCLE THAT
THE SECRETARY STATE WITHOUT OUR
AUTHORIZATION. SPENT THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR NO BID
CONTRACT. FOR VOTER OUT REACH
THAT SAME FIRM THAT DID THAT
FOR HER OUT REACH. HAPPENED TO
ALSO DO PARTISAN WORKED IN FIVE
DIFFERENT RACES FOR TARGETED
CONGRESSIONAL RACES. IN MY
STATE SENATE SEE WHERE MY
OPPONENT SPENT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS WITH THE SAME
FIRM. I ASKED THE NEW SECRETARY
STATE WHEN SHE CAME ON BOARD
DURING THE PROCESS. IF I COULD
SEE THE WORK PRODUCT BECAUSE I
WOULD I'D LIKE TO SEE. THIS AND
HAVE MY CONCERNS ARE LAID AND-
LONE BEHOLD IT NEVER IT NEVER
CAME. WE MEMBERS WE CAN'T
PEOPLE CAN'T TRUST OUR
DEMOCRACY IF THEY CAN'T TRUST
THE LATORRE PROCESS. AND ALL
WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
TRANSPARENCY SO THERE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY SO WE CAN HAVE
SOME TRUST SO. BITTER FIFTEEN
MILLION I GUESS WE'VE GOT TO DO
IT I TELL YOU THAT'S THE MOST
EXPENSIVE-MAIL IN THE HISTORY
OF THE WORLD- BUT HAVING SAID
THAT I JUST CAN'T SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE AGAIN. HERE YOU GO
AGAIN AND WE CAN DO BETTER THAN
THIS. SO I ASK FOR NO THOUGH
THANK YOU SENATOR WILSON-
NIELSEN. THAT IS PRESENTLY JAM
THE SENATE I RAISED MY CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS EARLIER. IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE TODAY. I RAISE
IT AGAIN. YOU KNOW IF YOUR FULL
ME ONCE IT'S ON ME BUT BEFORE
TWICE NO IT'S NOT ON ME ANYMORE
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE THE LAST TIME AROUND WE
SECRETARY OF STATE NO BID
CONTRACT VERY PARTISAN ENTITY
HIRED. NO CONTROL HERE NO INPUT
HERE AND HERE WE GO AGAIN. YOU
KNOW THIS JUST REEKS OF
PARTISANSHIP AND WE NEED TO
STOP THERE I URGE A NO VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER NELSON MEMBERS
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
SANDERS CAN OR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA. HI AT KINS.
HI BASE. NO BACKER. HI FOR JUST
NO BRADFORD HI COME BY OTHER HI
CORTESE I DALLY NO DOT. I
THEY'RE AWESOME HI EGGAN. I
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE.
NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO I JONES NO KAMMERER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MOST.
FIVE MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN.
I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO OCHO
ALTHOUGH NO PAN HI FORTUNE TINO
HI RALPH HI RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN HI AMBERG HI Y. CASI FIVE
WINNER I WILL. NO FIVE THIRTY
ONE KNOWS NINETY ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WE'RE STILL IN
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER TWO
WE'RE MOVING TO FILE AND ONE OH
ONE WHICH IS S. B. ONE FORTY
TWO AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY TWO BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND AFTER
RELATING TO STATE EMPLOYMENT
AND MAKING IT MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SANDERS CAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SP ONE FORTY TWO
PROVIDES THE LEGISLATIVE
RATIFICATION FOR THE
MEMORANDUMS OF UNDERSTANDING.
THAT WERE. COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED BETWEEN. THE STATE
AND NINETEEN OF OUR STATE
EMPLOYEE UNITS. THE NEW. M. O.
U. AGREEMENTS END THE PERSONAL
LEAVE PROGRAM. WHICH WAS
ADOPTED TO ADDRESS THE
PROJECTED BUDGET SHORTFALL IN
TWENTY TWENTY DEPENDING ON THE
BARGAINING UNIT STATE EMPLOYEE
PAY. IN THAT LAST YEAR WAS
REDUCED BY EITHER FOUR POINT
62% OR NINE POINT 23% AND
INSTEAD EMPLOYEES EARNED
PERSONAL LEAVE CREDIT. OR AN
EQUIVALENT AMOUNT. THESE NEW
AGREEMENTS MEAN THAT EMPLOYERS
WILL NO LONGER HAVE THEIR PAY
REDUCED I WILL NO LONGER
RECEIVE PERSONAL CREDIT.
PERSONAL LEAVE EACH MONTH. THE
NEW CONTRACTS ALSO RESTORE
EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS FOR
PREPAID RETIREE HEALTH BENEFITS
AS PART OF LAST YEAR'S.
PERSONAL LEAVE PROGRAM AND THE
REDUCTIONS THAT WE MADE THE
EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS WERE
SUSPENDED STATE EMPLOYEES UNDER
THESE AGREEMENTS WILL RESUME
CONTRIBUTING A PERCENTAGE OF
THEIR PAY TO PRE FUND THEIR
RETIREE BENEFITS. HEALTH
BENEFITS THE NEW AGREEMENTS
RESTORE SUSPENDED OR DEFERRED
COMPENSATION INCREASES. THAT
PREVIOUSLY WERE SCHEDULED FOR
TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THESE AGREEMENTS IMPLEMENT
THE COMPENSATION INCREASES THAT
THE BARGAINING UNITS EITHER
GAVE UP OR AGREED TO
TEMPORARILY SUSPEND. THE MO USE
INCLUDES SALARY INCREASES FOR
SOME OF THE BARGAINING UNITS
BUT EXCEPT IN THE CASE OF A
FEW. SPECIAL EMPLOYEE
CLASSIFICATIONS NONE OF THE NEW
SALARY INCREASES AS MORE THAN
TWO POINT 5% ABOVE WHAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY SCHEDULED. FINALLY
THE BILL RATIFIES OTHER
NEGOTIATED CHANGES TO THE
VARIOUS O USE BETWEEN THE
STATE AND THE NINETEEN
BARGAINING UNITS THIS BILL
APPROPRIATES ONE POINT THREE
BILLION. TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THE SAMO USE WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. BUT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT I PLEASE.
BECKER I'M SORRY FOR JUSTICE HI
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HIGH
COURTESY FIVE DALLY. DODD HI
THERE ALSO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER
HI CONSOLIDATES I GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
HI JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED
HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE. HI
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEN. I
NEWMAN I NELSON BY A SHOW OF
VOGUE. I CAN HI FOURTEEN TO NO.
HI RALPH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER I
STERN I AM BERG. HI WHITE HOUSE
D. HI WINNER I WILL. HI PLEASE
CALL THE OFFICE AND MEMBERS.
VALLEY HI. JONES. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING BACK TO
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE AND WE'RE GOING TO FILE
ITEM NINETY NINE A. B. NUMBER
ONE FIFTY NINE BETTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FIFTY NINE BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO STATE EMPLOYMENT
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET SENATOR SKINNER. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY NINE IS THE
SECOND TIME- YOU BUILD THAT WE
WILL TAKE UP TONIGHT AND IT
PROVIDES LEGISLATIVE
RATIFICATION OF AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
BARGAINING UNIT SIX WHICH IS
REPRESENTED BY OUR CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION. THE NEW AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE STATE FAIR CCPOA
ENDS THE PERSONAL LEAVE PROGRAM
WHICH REDUCED EMPLOYEE PAY BY
FOUR POINT 62% IN TWENTY
TWENTY. THE NEW CONTRACT ALSO
REINSTATES THE 4% EMPLOYEE
CONTRIBUTION WHAT THE EMPLOYEE
HAS TO PAY. TOWARDS PREPAID
RETIREE HEALTH BENEFITS. IT
ALSO RESTORES A PREVIOUSLY
SCHEDULED 3% SALARY ADJUSTMENT
FROM TWENTY TWENTY. AND
INCREASES IT BY AN ADDITIONAL
TWO POINT 5% FOR A TOTAL OF
FIVE POINT 5% WHICH WILL BECOME
EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR. IT ALSO PROVIDES ANOTHER
SALARY INCREASE OF TWO POINT 5%
FOR JULY TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE
AGREEMENT REESTABLISHES HOLIDAY
PAY THE NIGHT AND WEEKEND
SHIFTS DIFFERENTIALS
DIFFERENTIALS AND THE PERSONAL
DEVELOPMENT DAY. EMPLOYEES WILL
EARN EIGHT HOURS OF COVERT
NINETEEN FATIGUE LOT LEAVE TIME
OFF FOR MONTHS THAT MUST BE
USED. BY JULY THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY OTHERWISE IT EXPIRES
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SKEWS ME THAT
FATIGUE LEAVE TIME OFF MUST BE
USED BY JULY THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE M. O. U.
PROVIDES EMPLOYEES WITH TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHT DOLLARS PER
MONTH WHICH WILL BE PAID IN A
SINGLE LUMP SUM. ONCE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND ONCE IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FOR A TOTAL OF FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN RECOGNITION
OF INCREASED HEALTH AND
WELLNESS NEEDS TIED TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
FINALLY EMPLOYEES WILL HAVE AN
OPTION TO CASH OUT UP TO EIGHTY
HOURS OF LEAVE CREDITS IN TOTAL
THIS BILL APROPRIATES FIVE
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS M. O. U. R. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR NIELSEN. MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE I'M USUALLY HAVE.
PRETTY HARD NOSE ON THESE MO
USE OVER THE MANY YEARS. BUT I
HAVEN'T BEEN ON THIS PARTICULAR
ONE. I HAVE HAD MY OWN
EXPERIENCES DEALING WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND I'LL CALL.
CCPO I CALLED IT THE TOUGHEST
BEAT. WELL I'M ALMOST IN
AGREEMENT THAT IT IS THE TOUGH
BEAT. THESE EMPLOYEES THEIR
DAILY LIVES ARE NOT EVER WITHIN
A PLEASANT ATMOSPHERE. OR
DEALING WITH NECESSARILY
PLEASANT ISSUES. AND THE
PRESSURES UPON THEM ARE
ENORMOUS SOMETIMES IT EBBS AND
FLOWS. BUT RIGHT NOW IT IS
CERTAINLY BETTER TO HAVE. AND
THEY DON'T HAVE MUCH SECURITY
ANYMORE HAS THIS GOVERNORS
DECIDED TO CLOSE MORE PRISONS.
NOW HIS GOAL THERE IS WHAT HE
CALLS A REALIGNMENT I GATHER
AND HE IS SOMEONE WHO SHOULD
NOT BE INCARCERATING EVERYBODY
WILL WANT AT THIS END GAMES
HERE. IS TO ENSURE THAT IN THE
FUTURE IF THE LEGISLATURE
DESIRES OF THE PEOPLE DEMAND AN
INCREASE IN SENTENCING IN ANY
WAY. THERE WON'T BE ANY ROOM AT
THE END NOW THAT'S A LITTLE
SUBTLE GOAL OF SOME OF THE
PROPONENTS OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM BUT LET'S GET BACK TO
THE ISSUE AT HAND. THE JOB OF
THOSE EMPLOYEES WHO WORK WITHIN
THE INSTITUTIONS. IT IS A RISKY
BUSINESS. IT IS A DEPRESSING
BUSINESS. I HAD TO WONDER
MYSELF HOW I WAS ABLE TO GO
HOME NIGHT AFTER NIGHT. A LOT
OF BAD DREAMS ABOUT WHAT I
EXPERIENCED DURING THE DAY
AHEAD. IT IS TOUGH IT'S TOUGH
FOR THE INMATES WITHIN THE
INSTITUTION. BUT MOST ASSUREDLY
THOSE WHO ARE THERE FOR
STUDENTS. AND THOSE WHO DO THE
HELP FOR THOSE INMATES
PROVIDING THEM REHABILITATIVE
OPPORTUNITIES. THIS IS A TOUGH
LEAGUE AND THESE INDIVIDUALS
DESERVE THE SAME- YOU HIRED A
NOVEL. THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON
SENATOR AMBER- THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- THAT IS
CORRECT CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
WORK IN A UNIQUE ENVIRONMENT. A
DANGEROUS ENVIRONMENT
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEY'RE IN
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO ONE ANOTHER
AND CLOCKS CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
THOSE THAT THEY GUARD MAINTAIN-
AND AS A CONSEQUENCE. THEY HAVE
DANGERS THAT THAT WE DON'T FACE
FOR EXAMPLE DANGERS WITH
RESPECT TO COVE IN NINETEEN.
ARE THEY CAN'T NECESSARILY
DISASSOCIATE THEMSELVES FROM
THOSE WHO DECLINED TO BE
VACCINATED WE CAN DO SO THEY
CAN'T NECESSARILY DISASSOCIATE
THEMSELVES FROM THOSE OF THE
REQUIRED TO GUARD. AND AS A
CONSEQUENCE I BELIEVE THERE'S
BEEN TWENTY EIGHT CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS WHO HAVE DIED FROM
CARBON NINETEEN AND TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN INMATES HAVE DIED
FROM COVERT NINETEEN- HOWEVER.
SADLY ONLY FIFTY ONE POINT 5%
OF THOSE WHO ARE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS HAVE BEEN VACCINATED.
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT. YOU
KNOW THIS WATER IS NOW GONE
BEYOND THE BRIDGE. BUT I'M
HOPEFUL THAT IN THE FUTURE WHEN
WE ENCOUNTER THIS KIND OF
CRISIS THAT THAT WE CAN DO
SOMETHING TO INCENTIVIZE THOSE
OR IF THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
CAN BE DONE- POST. ADOPTION MO
YOU TO INCENTIVIZE THOSE
PRISON- CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
TO DO SO THAT THAT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE US TO CREATE THOSE
INCENTIVES TO MAKE SURE THAT
BOTH THEY AND THOSE THAT THEY
GUARD REMAIN SAFE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THE CENTER I'M
BERG. THIRD ALI. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT. AS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR FOR SIXTEEN YEARS I
REPRESENTED- CCC AND HIGH
DESERT AND LASSEN COUNTY. I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF DEBATE
OVER THESE CONTRACTS AND- AND-
AND HOW MUCH THEY GET PAID IN
THEIR COMPENSATION AND I WILL
JUST SHARE WITH YOU. I KNOW
MANY OF THESE. MEN AND WOMEN
WHO WORK THERE THEY'RE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS- AND THEN
COMING TO THE SENATE ACTUALLY
INHERITED THE FOLSOM. PRISON AS
WELL AND I WOULD JUST WANT TO
SEE- IF YOU IF YOU HAVEN'T
TOURED A PRISON AND YOU HAVEN'T
SEEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE
PLATE PLACES WHERE THEY HAVE TO
WORK YOU SHOULD. THE RATE OF.
SPOUSAL ABUSE THE RATE FOR
CHILDREN SO. THAT THEY COME
THEY'RE THEY'RE WORKING
ENVIRONMENT COMES HOME WITH
THEM. THEY NEED TO BE THEY NEED
TO HAVE THE TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
THEM. TO BE ABLE TO GET MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND THE LIKE SO
FOR THOSE REASONS I STAND WITH
THEM. THEIR CENTER WORKERS AND
I THINK THIS IS A GOOD. STEP
FORWARD IN HELPING THEM. DO
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO PROTECT
US SO I. URGE AND I VOTE ON. A.
B. ONE FIFTY FIVE NINE. THANK
YOU SENATOR HOLLINGS MEMBERS
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NINE
CENTER ST ORIGINALLY TO CLOSE.
I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS I BASICS HI BECKER.
GORGEOUS HIGH BRADFORD I CAN'T
BUY A HI COURTESY I DALLY I
DONT HI TORONTO. HI AIKMAN.
GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ HI GROSS.
HI HEARD SPURRED BY WESTERN HI
HER TADO I JONES. CAM WALKER.
FIVE LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MON
HI MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. FIVE
MEN. HI NEWMAN I NIELSEN I.
OTERO OF BOTH HI PAN. I FORTUNE
TINO I BROUGHT. HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI STERN I AM BERG HI
WHITE HOUSE E. FIVE WINNER. NO
WILKE. HI PLEASE CALL THE OF
THE MEMBERS. ALAN BACKER.
EGGMAN JONES. FIVE THIRTY FIVE
NEWS TO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO
TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS-
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO SENATOR%
BATES WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT OF VIOLET M. TWENTY
ONE OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
DOCTOR TOMAS OREGON. STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER AND
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT DR
OREGON SERVED FOR A DECADE IS
HOW FAR OFFICER AND DIRECTOR OF
THE POPULATION. HEALTH DIVISION
FOR THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE JUNE TWENTY
THIRD ON A UNANIMOUS FIVE ZERO
VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR WIENER. FIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT- DOCTOR AROUND WHO
IS SOMEONE I'VE KNOWN AND
WORKED WITH FOR MANY MANY YEARS
IN SAN FRANCISCO. HE WAS OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER FOR
HEALTH OFFICER FOR MANY YEARS-
AND PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN
GUIDING THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO. THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND REALLY DID
YEOMAN'S WORK IS A VERY
THOUGHTFUL KNOWLEDGEABLE-
REALLY DECENT HUMAN BEING AND-
I FULLY SUPPORT HIS
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING THEN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA I AT KINS I BASE. I
BACKER I FOR JUST I BRADFORD I
CUT BY ADAM HI CORTESE HI DALLY.
GOD HI THERE ALSO I EGGMAN. HI
LASER EYE CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH. HI HURTS BERG I WAS SO
HI HER TADO HI JONES. I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I
LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S I MEN. HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN
I PORTS AND TINA I BROUGHT. HI
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I STERN I AM
BERG I LIKE HOW C. I. WINNER HI
WELK. HI THE QUALITY OF THE
NUMBER. DALLY HI HIGHS FORTY NO
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO
SENATOR BATES. PILOT IN NUMBER
TWENTY TWO IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF DARCY HOW ODD TO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION BEFORE
BEING APPOINTED AS A
COMMISSIONER MISS HOW SERVED AS
THE CHIEF COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION AS
AN END OF AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE AT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE TWENTY THIRD
ON A UNANIMOUS FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THINK CENTRE BATES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE.SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS I BASE I BECKER I FORGES.
BRADFORD HI CUT BY ADAM I
CORTESE HI DALLY. DOT FIVE
TORONTO HI ADNAN I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH HI
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HIGH HER
TADO. HI JONES. CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. OTOBO HI PAM
I FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN HI
AMBERG HI WAY CASKEY FIVE
WINNER I WELL. I IT'S CLEAR
SOME MEMBERS. ALAN HI FORGES.
DALLY JONES. MELINDA'S NIELSEN
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED TO
MOVING THE FILE I'M TWENTY
THREE SENATOR BATES FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY THREE IS A
CONFIRMATION OF SHAR LANA PELOS
CO TWO THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
CONTROL APPEALS BOARD MUSICAL
OSSEO PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS AN
ASSISTANT TO COMMISSIONER FRANK
BRASS OF THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION APPEALS BOARD IN
FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS WAS A
BILLING ADMINISTRATOR FOR A LAW
FIRM FOR ANTI AND CHRISTOPHER
SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE TWENTY THIRD
ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA I AT
KINS I BASE. HI BECKER HI OR
JUST HI BRADFORD HI BY ADAM HI
CORTESE FIVE DALLY HI DODD. HI
THERE ARE SO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER
I CONSOLIDATES I GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO. HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON. I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN I NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF
VOGUE HI PAM. I PORTS AND TINA
I. ROSS HI RUBIO HI SKINNER
FIVE STERN HI AMBERG HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI. HI WINNER I WILL. HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER.
MELINDA'S. FIVE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MEMBERS FOR ME TO
FILE I DON'T TWENTY FOUR
SENATOR BATES VIOLATE HIM
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF ARTHUR CROWNS
FOR REAPPOINTMENT TO THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RELATIONS BOARD MR
KRAUSS HAS SERVED ON THE BOARD
SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN PRIOR TO
THIS POSITION HE WAS A PARTNER
AT LAW FIRM LEONARD CARDER ELLO
P. HE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE TWENTY THIRD
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOAT THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA I AT
KINS HI BASED FIVE BACKER HI
FORGES HI BRADFORD. BRADFORD I
COME BY AT A HIGH COURTESY I
DALLY. I DONT. HI THERE ARE SO
HI ADNAN. I GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG HI WEST SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LLEVA HI LYNN MON.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S BY MEN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. A CHECK. BUT
SHOW BOTH I PANNED BY FORTUNE
TINO. HI RALPH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI STERN FIVE AMBERG HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE WINNERS I
WILL. HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THE MON HI. NIELSEN HI.
BUYS FORTY NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
FIFTEEN MEMBERS YOU HAVE BEFORE
YOU SENATE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
NUMBER THREE I'M GOING TO GO TO
FILE ITEM ONE OF SIX SP ONE
TWENTY NINE. L. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
YEAH. SENATE BILL
ONE TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR
SKINNER AN ACT RELATING TO THE
STATE BUDGET AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET
BELL CENTRE SKINNER THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP ONE
TWENTY NINE IS THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR WHICH IS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THIS BILL MAKES TECHNICAL
AND SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES TO THE
BUDGET ON JUNE FOURTEENTH THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB ONE
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH REPRESENTED
THE LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET
AGREEMENT. AB OR SB ONE TWENTY
NINE WHICH IS BEFORE US RIGHT
NOW CONTAINS AMENDMENTS BASED
OFF OUR LEGISLATIVE BUDGET BILL.
THAT REPRESENTS THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. AN AGREEMENT
THAT MAINTAINS MOST OF THE KEY
ELEMENTS OF BOTH THE
LEGISLATORS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS. IN THE WAKE OF A
FIFTEEN MONTH PANDEMIC THAT
pSUFFERING ON SO MANY HOUSEHOLDS
BUSINESSES. MORE THIS IS WHAT
THIS BUDGET. CALIFORNIA IS
BUILDING BACK BOLDLY THIS IS A
GOOD NEWS BUDGET. IT REPRESENTS
TOTAL GENERAL FUND SPENDING A
HUNDRED NINETY SIX POINT FOUR
BILLION ANY FUNDS OUR SCHOOLS
AT THE HIGHEST PROP NINETY
EIGHT LEVEL EVER NINETY THREE
POINT SEVEN BILLION
REPRESENTING TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND PER STUDENT. AS IT
MAKES CALIFORNIA THE FIRST
STATE IN THE NATION TO PROVIDE
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS. WITH
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
CHILD CARE SLOTS. OVER TIME
EXPANDED PRESCHOOL T. K. AND
AFTER SCHOOL THIS BUDGET
SUPPORTS OUR CHILDREN AGE ZERO
TO FIVE BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY IT
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA WOMEN GET
BACK TO WORK. AND IN A YEAR
WHERE THE NECESSITY OF HELP
CLEAR HEALTHCARE WAS CLEARER
THAN EVER. WE HAVE EXPANDED
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. AND
SUPPORT FOR OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ARE
PROVIDING ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE AGE FIFTY
AND ABOVE WITH MEDI CAL
COVERAGE AND WE HAVE ENDED THE
ASSET TEST BED EXPANDED
PRENATAL AND POSTNATAL SERVICES
UNDER MEDICARE. PIRATE WITH THE
PREPARATION IN THIS BUDGET MORE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WILL BE
ABLE TO ATTEND ARE YOU SEE AND
CSU'S SYSTEMS ANY INCREASES IN
FINANCIAL AID OUR CALGARY ANTS
IN OUR MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP.
SETS US ON A PATH TO DEBT FREE
COLLEGE AND FOR THE FIRST TIME
PROVIDES FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
TO CALIFORNIA TO START
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LATER IN
LIFE. WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO
DEVELOP NEW JOB SKILLS SO
IMPORTANT IN THIS POST PANDEMIC
AIR. THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
TO WHICH IS CONTAINED IN THIS
BUDGET PUTS ADDITIONAL MONEY
DIRECTLY INTO THE POCKETS OF
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES AND
FAMILIES WITH DEPENDENTS. AND
THERE IS ADDITIONAL GRANT
FUNDING FOR OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES OR NONPROFITS AND
OUR ARTS MUSIC AND CULTURAL
VENUES ALL WERE SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC. AND
WITH TWELVE BILLION INVESTMENT
OVER TWO YEARS INCLUDING ONE
BILLION A FLEXIBLE FUNDING TO
OUR LARGEST CITIES ONE BILLION
PER YEAR FOR TWO YEARS WE'RE
MAKING A VERY SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT TOWARDS ENDING
HOMELESSNESS. OUR FOOD BANKS
DIAPER BANKS BAND FOR THE FIRST
TIME WE ARE INCLUDING MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS IN THOSE BANKS GET A
BOOST AND WE SET A PATH TOWARD
ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS FOOD ASSISTANCE SO THAT
WE CAN BEGIN TO COME COME BACK.
FOOD INSECURITY AND HUNGER
WHICH IS SO RAMPANT
UNFORTUNATELY IN OUR STATE. OUR
ACCESS TO JUSTICE INVESTMENT
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL LEGAL AID
ELIMINATE MANY COURT FEES AND
ALLOW FAMILIES TO SPEAK WITH
THEIR INCARCERATED RELATIVES
FOR A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME
FREE OF CHARGE. MANY OF US HAVE
BEEN FIGHTING SINCE THE
RECESSIONTO PULL UP THE
SUPPORT FOR SSI AND S. S. P.
RECIPIENTS AND TO THOSE WHO
PROVIDE CARE FOR OUR DISABLED
FOLKS. AND ALSO THE SUPPORT TO
OUR LOWEST INCOME FAMILIES WHO
RECEIVE CALL WORKS. WITH THIS
BUDGET ALL RECEIVE RATE
INCREASES. THE BUDGET ALSO
MAKES MAJOR INVESTMENTS IN
WILDFIRE DROUGHT CLIMATE
RESILIENCY ENERGY AND
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FINDS
DETAILS WHICH WILL COME BEFORE
US LATER BUT THE DOLLARS ARE
HERE. AND IT INVESTS IN
BROADBAND SO WE CAN ADDRESS THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IT'S SO IMPACTED.
WE ALL BEGAN TO LIVE ENTIRELY
THROUGH THE INTERNET IN THIS
LAST PERIOD OF TIME WHETHER IT
WAS FOR SCHOOL FOR MEETINGS FOR
WORK AND IT BECAME MORE AND
MORE APPEAR WHAT AN ESSENTIAL
PUBLIC SERVICE THE INTERNET AND
BROADBAND ACCESS IS. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THIS BUDGET
PRIORITIZES RESPONSIBLE
BUDGETING. IT CONTAINS TWENTY
FIVE POINT TWO BILLION IN TOTAL
RESERVES THE HIGHEST STATE
RESERVE EVER AND IT FULLY PAYS
OFF FOR EDUCATION FOR GIRLS.
OUR PAST YEARS OF RESPONSIBLE
BUDGETING OUR STATE'S
PROGRESSIVE TAX SYSTEM AND A
MUCH NEEDED FEDERAL STIMULUS
FUNDS HAVE MADE ALL OF THIS
POSSIBLE. MEMBERS THIS BILL
REPRESENTS A BUDGET AGREEMENT
WE SHOULD ALL BE PROUD OF I AM
PROUD OF BEEN WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
ATKINS. MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU AND- COLLEAGUES WITH THANKS
TO OUR COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY
OUR BUDGET CHAIR I FEEL LIKE I
RISE TODAY WITH A GREAT SENSE
OF OPTIMISM THANK YOU FOR
THOSE- THE OUTLINE OF ALL THAT
WE WERE ABLE TO DO IN THIS
BUDGET. FROM DAY ONE I'VE SAID
THAT THIS BUDGET IS A ONCE IN A
WHILE GENERATION OPPORTUNITY
MAKE TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE. A
CHANCE TO NOT ONLY CHECK BOXES
BUT TO CHANGE LIVES. AND THAT'S
WHAT THE BUDGET PACKAGE BEFORE
US TODAY DOES. WELL OUR STATE
IS EMERGING FROM THE PANDEMIC
MANY WORKING FAMILIES SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND THE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG US ARE STILL
STRUGGLING. EACH OF US HAS
SPENT TIME ON THE GROUND IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND TALKING TO OUR
NEIGHBORS TO UNDERSTAND THEIR
NEEDS. THIS BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS IT'S A REFLECTION
OF ALL OF OUR COLLECTIVE VOICES
AND INPUT. IT'S ALSO A PRODUCT
OF THE GREAT PARTNERSHIP THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND WE HAVE A
STRONGER BUDGET TO SHOW FOR
THAT. OF COURSE NONE OF THIS
WOULD HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE IF NOT
FOR THE TIRELESS WORK THAT MANY
HOURS OUR STAFF IS DEDICATED TO
IT. TO THE LA- THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE LEDGE COUNCIL AND
OUR OWN BUDGET STAFF SO THANK
YOU TO ALL OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. THIS IS BEEN A
CHALLENGING YEAR. BUT YOU ROSE
TO THE OCCASION. NOW OVER A
DECADE OF RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING
COMBINED WITH THE ROBUST
FEDERAL STIMULUS ACTIONS WE
RECEIVED THIS YEAR. AND A
COMMON SENSE VOTER APPROVED
REVENUE SYSTEM WE'RE IN A
POSITION TO CREATE THE MOST
RESPONSIBLE MOST TRANSFORMATIVE
AND BOLD THE STATE BUDGET IN
MODERN HISTORY. A BUDGET THAT
WILL CONTINUE PUSHING OUR STATE
FORWARD AS WE BUILD BACK.
CREATING A PATH TO RECOVERY
WIDE ENOUGH FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO SHARE. IT WILL
HELP MOR SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS OPENED THEIR DOORS
WELCOME IN A STREAM OF
CUSTOMERS AND HIRE EMPLOYEES SO
MORE PEOPLE CAN GET BACK TO
WORK. FOR FAMILIES WITH OLDER
CHILDREN THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP REBOOT WILL MEAN
NOT HAVING TO DIP INTO A FOUR
OH ONE K. OR GO INTO DEBT TO
GET A COLLEGE EDUCATION. AN
IMPORTANT STEPPING STONE FOR
MANY CREERS AND A KEY BUILDING
BLOCK FOR A STRONG MIDDLE CLASS.
THE EXPANDED NUTRITION BENEFITS
WILL MEAN THAT PEOPLE SHUT OUT
FROM THE FOOD ASSISTANCE DUE TO
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS. WILL
HAVE FULL BELLIES WHEN THEY
CLOCK IN AT WORK OR GET OFF THE
SCHOOL BUS. AFTER ALL. NO ONE
CAN BE EXPECTED TO CONCENTRATE
LET ALONE SUCCEED WITH MOWING
HUNGER IN THE PIT OF THEIR
STOMACH. THE SAME GOES FOR YOU
DO NOT HAVE A SAFE SECURE HOME
TO RETURN HOME TO AT THE END OF
THE DAY. THE RECORD LEVEL
INVESTMENTS THIS PACKAGE MAKES
IN ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS AND
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WILL MEAN THAT MORE FAMILIES
WILL HAVE A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEAD. AND A PLACE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN TO DREAM AT NIGHT.
SUMMER HAS ONLY JUST BEGUN BUT
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS BEEN
SWEATING THROUGH HIGH HEAT. AND
INTENSIFYING DROUGHT. THE
FUND'S LAID OUT IN THIS
AGREEMENT WILL ENSURE FARMERS.
BUSINESSES COMMUNITIES AND
FAMILIES THAT RELY ON WATER TO
SURVIVE. ARE NOT LEFT DESERTED
AS THE DROUGHT CONDITIONS
WORSEN. THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
I WAS REALLY BLOWN AWAY BY HOW
CALIFORNIANS SHOWED UP FOR EACH
OTHER FOR ONE ANOTHER. THE
NEIGHBORS WHO CHECKED IN THE
FOLKS WHO SEWED MASK THE FOOD
BANK VOLUNTEERS THAT DELIVERED
BAGS OF GROCERIES AND HOT
MEALS. THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THAT PUT THEIR OWN HEALTH AT
RISK TO SHOW UP FOR US EVERY
SINGLE DAY. OUR COMMUNITY
SHOWED US THE TRUE MEANING OF
THE CALIFORNIA WAY. NOW AS WE
CAN FOLLOW WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FOLLOW THEIR
LEAD WITH THIS BUDGET WE WILL
EXTEND MORE OPPORTUNITY AND
PROSPERITY TO EVERYONE ACROSS
THE GOLDEN STATE AS WE CONTINUE
TO BUILD BACK FROM A VERY
DIFFICULT YEAR. THANK YOU ALL
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR PART IN
YOUR INPUT IN THIS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS
CENTER BRADFORD. FROM PRESIDENT
I. T. RISES TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR THIS INCREDIBLE BUDGET
THANK THE PROTEIN FOR AMAZING
LEADERSHIP OUR BUDGET HERE FOR
ALL THE HARD WORK. THAT SHE HAS
DONE IS WELL OVERDUE FOR STAFF
AND THE GOVERNOR AND I AND HIS
TEAM FOR THE HARD WORK IN
BRINGING THIS BUDGET TOGETHER.
THIS IS A BUDGET THAT IS
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE BY PAYING
DOWN DEBT AND DEFERRALS AT THE
SAME TIME IT CREATES A STRONG
PATHWAY THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
FROM THE CHAOS THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED OVER THE LAST YEAR
TO THIS PANDEMIC. AND IT'S HERE
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AND ON BEHALF THE
CALL BECAUSE I WANT TO EXPRESS
THE GRATITUDE. FOR THIS BUDGET
INVESTMENT THAT WILL IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
CALIFORNIANS. CAN THAT WILL
HELP TO CLOSE THE VARIOUS AND
NUMEROUS DISPARITIES THAT EXIST
IN OUR SOCIETY MANY THAT WERE
AMPLIFIED AND SHOWN DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. THIS QUICKLY EXAMPLE
OF SOME OF THOSE THINGS THAT
WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
FUNDING OF THE UCLA. RALPH J.
BUNCHE CENTER. THE FINDING OF
THE UCLA LABOR CENTER AND IS
RENOVATIONS AND RENAMING OF
THAT SOONER AFTER CIVIL RIGHTS
ICON. THE REVEREND JAMES LAWSON
AND IT WILL BE NOW THE REVEREND
JAMES LAWSON. CALL WORKERS
JUSTICE CENTER THE FUNDING OF
CAL STATE DOMINGUEZ HILLS TO
ADDRESS INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS.
DESPITE BEING ONE OF THE NEWEST
CAMPUSES IT'S IN. DIRE NEED OF
REPAIR AND IT'S A CAMPUS THAT
ROLLS OUT OF THE NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE WATTS RIOTS SO IT'S
VITALLY IMPORTANT IN EDUCATING.
A VERY DIVERSE POPULATION MORE
SO THAN ANY OF OUR C. ISSUES IN
THE STATE. AND ALSO FUNDING TO
ASSIST CANNABIS EQUITY
APPLICANTS AND LICENSEES WITH
LICENSE FEE WAIVERS WHICH IS
GREAT A GREATLY IMPORTANT. WE
HEAR ON A REGULAR BASIS THE
CHALLENGES OF PEOPLE OF COLOR
HAVING- ENTERING THE SPACE BUT
WE KNOW. THE WARRANT DRUGS HAS
HAD AN IMPACT IT'S HAD ON THOSE
COMMUNITIES OF LOS FORTY YEARS.
AND THE FUNNY THE CHARLES JUDE
UNIVERSITY- SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
AND SCIENCE- AGAIN GRADUATING
MORE MINORITY DOCTORS IN ANY
MEDICAL SCHOOL. IN THE COUNTRY.
AND FUNDING OF THE MERMAN
DONNELLY AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC
INSTITUTE. AT CAL STATE
DOMINGUEZ HILLS. AND THE
FINDING OF THE DEBBIE ALLEN
DANCE STUDIO WHICH IS.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. TO MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WANT TO.
PRACTICE STARTS S. HERE PUBLIC
SAFETY I'M ALSO ECOURAGED TO
SEE THE BUDGET INCLUDE ITEMS
THAT AFFIRM. THE AMENITY OF
PEOPLE. AND OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
INCLUDING FUNDING TO ELIMINATE
CRIMINAL FEES AT HARM SO MANY
PEOPLE CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY
THEM THE FUNDING- FIVE CAREER
DEVELOPMENT REHABILITATION. THE
ABILITY TO TAILOR PROGRAMS AND
LOCAL SUPPORT FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO REMAIN OUT OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND FUNDING OF
CDC ARE FOR SIXTY MINUTES
TELEPHONE CALLS REACHING
CARBURETOR PERSON EVERY TWO
WEEKS. THE ADDITION OF THE
THIRD DAY IN PERSON VISITATION
ON FRIDAYS TO ALL INSTITUTIONS
ARE FREE TRANSPORTATION ON
SELECT DAYS THE VISITORS AT THE
PRESENT THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
I'M ALSO GRATEFUL FOR THE
INVESTMENT AGAIN- IN MY
DISTRICT ON THE VARIOUS THINGS
THAT WILL HELP IMPROVE THE
COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE AND FIND A
LOOK FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
DISCUSSION ON CANNABIS EQUITY
AND HOW FEE WAIVERS WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED. AS WELL AS HOW
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE IN
ADOPTION PROGRAMS WILL BE
STRUCTURED I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS THE- BUDGET AND I COULD
NOT ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
SANDERS CAN WE TAKE A QUESTION
YES HELLO PLEASE PROCEED. HOW
DOES THE MEASURE RESTORED THE
NET OPERATING LOSS DEDUCTION
AND BUSINESS INCENTIVE TAX
CREDITS THAT WERE SUSPENDED AND
CAPTAIN THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET. LET ME CHECK I DON'T
BELIEVE SO BUT ALLOW ME TO
RETURN TO THAT ANSWER FOR YOU
OKAY. WELL ON MY OWN TIME LET
ME GIVE MY ARM OF TALKING
POINTS ON SOMETHING I FEEL IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THE ACTION
WAS TAKEN AS PART OF LAST
YEAR'S STRATEGY TO CLOSE AN
ESTIMATED FIFTY FOUR BILLION.
DOLLAR BUDGET DEFICIT AND THAT
WAS A DEFICIT THAT NEVER CAME
TO FRUITION SUNSETTING THE
SUSPENSION AND CAP WOULD ASSIST
EMPLOYERS IN THEIR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY INCENTIVIZE THEM TO
REMAIN IN CALIFORNIA. THE
BUSINESS INCENTIVE TAX CREDIT
CAP WAS PARTICULARLY TROUBLING
CONSIDERING MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYERS ARE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN RESEARCHING
AND DEVELOPING CORBETT NINETEEN
VACCINES AND ANTIVIRAL
THERAPIES ACTIVITY THE STATE
SHOULD ENCOURAGE IT MATTERS
VERY MUCH- CENTURY AND I IN MY
DISTRICT. ADDITIONALLY WHAT IT
WHAT THE BUDGET DOES NOT APPEAR
TO DO THIS TO CLEAN ANY FUNDS
TO REDUCE THE STATE'S
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FIND OUT
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY A TAX ON
BUSINESSES OR TAKE ANY OTHER
STEPS TO ASSIST BUSINESS WITH A
COST REPAYMENT. WELL THERE ARE
SOME ITEMS IN THE BUDGET THAT
ARE CERTAINLY LAUDABLE WHEN WE
DO NOT CONSIDER THE FATE AND
THE- THE FINANCE OF THE
EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE OF THE
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE. THEY
ARE THE ECONOMIC ENGINE OF OUR
ECONOMY THAT KEEPS THE STATE
GOLDEN SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT REALLY SHOULDBE
CONSIDERED AS WE GO FORWARD ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE BUSINESS
NEEDS OUR HELP. IN IT EVERY
TURN. THEY SEEM TO BE GET THE
SHORT STEP. I GENOVA. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES INSIDERS CAN-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT
IN YOUR CLOTHES OR OR NOW I'LL
JUST- RESPONDED I WAS CORRECT
NO THIS BUDGET IS NOT. RESTORED
THE NET. OPERATING LOSS TAX
CREDIT HOWEVER THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF TAX CREDITS AND GRANT
PROGRAMS IN THE BUDGET THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED. AT
ASSISTING BUSINESSES IMPACTED
BY COMPANY. THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER CENTER EGLIN. I THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A.
B. ONE TWENTY NINE- I CAN TALK
ABOUT A LOT OF THE WONDERFUL
THINGS IN THIS BUDGET BUT I
JUST WANT TO FOCUS ON AS A
BUDGET SUB THREE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AND AS A SOCIAL
WORKER AS A MENTAL HEALTH
PRACTITIONER I JUST AS SOME SO
PROUD OF THIS HISTORIC.
INVESTMENTS WE'RE MAKING IN
THIS MEASURE TODAY- THERE'S NOT
MANY TIMES WHEN YOU WE WORKIN
A CAREER LIFE AND THEN YOU GET
TO COME TO THE LEGISLATURE WHEN
IT'S ACTUALLY A GOOD YEAR AND
YOU'RE REALLY ABLE TO FIND THE
THINGS THAT YOU CARE ABOUT SO
MUCH- THIS BILL AMONG THE
MENTAL HEALTH INVESTMENTS OVER
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE
YEARS TO ESTABLISH A MODERN
INNOVATIVE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SYSTEM FOR KIDS WE ALL TALK
ABOUT THE NEED FOR KIDS DRESSES
IN THIS. BUDGET TWO HUNDRED
FIVE MILLION FOR MENTAL HEALTH
STUDENT STUDENT SERVICES ACTIVE
FUND FULTON COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE
ALREADY READY TO GO OUT THE
DOOR RIGHT NOW MORE THAN TWO
POINT TWO FIVE THREE TWO POINT
TWO BILLION FOR COMPETITIVE
GRANTS TO CONSTRUCT ACQUIRE AND
REHABILITATE REAL PROPERTY TO
EXPAND THE COMMITTEE CONTINUE A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT WE
ALL SEE ALL THESE FOLKS ON THE
STREET WE COULD KEEP THINKING
WHY CAN'T SOMETHING BE DONE ONE
OF THE LACK OF BAD SELECT
FACILITIES A LACK OF. STRUCTURE
FOR THAT THIS WILL GO A LONG
LONG WAY TO HOPEFULLY ACTUALLY
DOING THAT FIXING THESE ISSUES
WHEN THESE FUNDS ALSO INCLUDES
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
PLUS FIFTY FIVE MILLION OF
FEDERAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THESE MOBILE HEALTH CRISIS
WE'RE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHY DO YOU HAVE
TO CALL THE POLICE WHY CAN'T
YOU CALL SOCIAL WORKER THESE
MOBILE HEALTH CRISIS TEAMS WILL
BE ABLE TO GO OUT AND ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES. THIS THIS MEMBERS
OF SOMETHING THAT I CAN TELL
YOU THE HUSBAND PILOT PROGRAMS
FOR EVER SHOWING THE AT THE
EFFICIENCY EFFICIENCY OF HAVING
MOBILE UNITS IN ACTION MENTAL
HEALTH WORKERS RESPOND OFTEN
TIMES IN CONJUNCTION WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND IT WORKS BUT
WE'VE NEVER BEEN ABLE TO FIND
IT BEFORE- AT SIX POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR
REDUCING CALIFORNIA DISPARITIES
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY'S BEEN
ABLE TO SEE IT LOOK AROUND THE
STATE WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING AND
I UNDERSTAND THE DISPARITIES
THAT ARE GOING ON. ALSO THE
ISSUES OF FOOD INSECURITY AS
SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS AN
AGRICULTURE DISTRICT- AND IT
LIVES IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AT.
KNOW THAT HAVE SOME. HUNG
PEOPLE. TOTALLY BREAKS ALL OF
OUR HEARTS. AND I'M SURE ALL OF
US. WERE AT SOME KIND OF FOOD
THEY GIVE AWAY SOME KIND OF
FOOD SOMETHING THAT WE DID OVER
THE PANDEMIC AND AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE COMING IN. ON WITH BIKES
WITH CARTS WITH STROLLERS TO
GET FOOD. IT'S HEARTBREAKING
THAT WERE ABLE TO. REALLY FIND.
OUR FOOD BANKS I THINK IS JUST
IS JUST TREMENDOUS- I'M- ALSO
GOING TO BE ABLE TO TURN. OUT
BETTER MEALS ON WHEELS TODAY
REALLY REDUCE. INSECURITY I
KEEP SAYING THAT TALK ABOUT
MEDICARE FOR ALL AND EVERYTHING
FOR ALL THAT FOR GOODNESS SAKES
WE CAN'T DO FOOD FOR ALL. WE
HAVE IT HERE LET'S GET IT OUT
TO THE FOLKS. THIS BUDGET GOES
A LONG WAY TOWARDS DOING THAT-
WE ALSO FOR THE FIRST TIME FOR
A LONG TIME ARE ABLE TO REALLY.
MAKE HEADWAY ON THE D. D. I. D.
RATES AT THE RATE STUDIES WE
KEEP SAYING THAT WE NEED TO.
PAY FOLKS EMBRACE NEED TO BE.
MATCHING A LOT OF FOLKS IN
THAT. THE DD POPULATION. CARE
GIVERS WERE STILL WORKING
DESPITE COVERT DESPITE
EVERYTHING. OFTEN TIMES NOT
BEING ABLE. TO GET. REIMBURSED
FOR THAT. THE ARE SO MANY
THINGS IN THIS BUDGET. I DON'T
THINK IT'S LOST ANY OF US AGAIN
THE DISPARITIES THAT EXISTED
THE ABILITY TO EXPAND MEDICAID
ALL DOWN TO FIFTY. UP FOR
PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF
DOCUMENTATION STATUS WE KNOW
THESE FOLKS HAVE BEEN WORKING
OUT IN OUR FIELD AND- IN OUR
RESTAURANTS AND ALL AROUND FOR
YEARS- THAT WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO ESPECIALLY IN YOUR FIFTIES
AS WHEN. WE ALL KNOW ABOUT YOUR
HEALTH CARE IS YOU START TO
BEGIN AT THE CHRONIC ONES AND
THAT'S THE TIME YOU WANT TO
CATCH PEOPLE BECAUSE IT'LL SAVE
MONEY- FOR LATER TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY GET PREVENTATIVE CARE
AND TREATMENT. SO THIS IS A
HISTORIC BUDGET AGAIN AS A
MENTAL HEALTH PRACTITIONER. I
AM SO PLEASED WITH WHAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO IT. I WANT TO
THANK THE PRO TEM I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR- AND THIS IS
NOW MY- NINETY HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT IS MY FIRST
TIME I HAVE SERVED ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. AND I AM
HUMBLED BY THE AMOUNT OF WORK
THAT GOES INTO THIS PROCESS.
AND REALLY WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF. AND ALL THE MEMBERS
THAT. THE MEMBER THE MEMBERS
THAT SAT FOR HOURS. IN
COMMITTEES AND PEOPLE WHO
CALLED IN. ON THE ADVOCATE SAID
THAT WE HEARD FROM- WE'RE DOING
THIS FOR CALIFORNIA. AND I
STRONGLY URGE AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR AIKMAN CENTER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TOO WANTED TO RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BUDGET IS VERY ROBUST AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED I TOO
WANT TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO-
THE SENATE BUDGET CHAIR IN OUR
SENATE LEADERSHIP TEAM A FEW
HIGHLIGHTS I WOULD LIKE TO
MENTION THE NEARLY BEEN
MENTIONED BEFORE BUT OF COURSE
IN ADDITION TO HISTORIC
EDUCATIONAL INVESTMENTS OF
COURSE MY FAVORITE BROADBAND
THREE POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR MIDDLE MILE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THOSE WERE
UNCONNECTED IN CALIFORNIA. SO
VERY IMPORTANT I'M GLAD THAT
THE SENATE HAS TAKEN THE LEAD
ON THIS UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
IN MY OWN BACK COURT YARD LIKE
SENATE- LIKE THE SOUTHEAST LOS
ANGELES IN CENTRAL LONG BEACH
HAVE BEEN UNDER INVESTED
LOCALLY FOR A VERY VERY LONG
TIME AND IS CHAIR OF
TRANSPORTATION SING ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO
SEEING JUST SOMETHING AS BASIC
AS GETTING OUR- FREEWAYS AND
HIGHWAYS CLEANED UP. WE KNOW
THAT THAT IS SO VERY IMPORTANT
TO FOR THAT THOSE REASONS AND
MORE I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT
I THINK- ALL OF THE TEAMS FOR
THEIR EFFORTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR GONZALES SENATOR
PAM. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CENTERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF- THIS- RESCUE ONE TWENTY
NINE AND- THIS TRULY HISTORIC-
BUDGETS AND THAT- WE ARE ABOUT
TO PASS HERE. TODAY REALLY
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK-
OUR LEADERSHIP. OUR BUDGET
STAFF WHICH WORKS SO HARD AND
ALSO I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO- WE HEARD FROM IN
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND HOURS AND
HOURS I KNOW THAT- MY GOOD
FRIEND- FROM STOCKTON- AS
HEARING BUT IT'S NOT JUST A-
DREAM THAT I WAS SO. PLEASED TO
JOIN HER. ON SEPT THREE- ALL
THE ALL THE INPUT THAT WE
RECEIVED FROM PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE- AND- THE IDEA ACTUALLY
HOURS OF TESTIMONY THAT THAT WE
HEARD IN TRYING TO CRAFT THIS
BUDGET- YOU KNOW MANY OF THE-
PRIOR SPEAKERS HAVE. TOUCHED ON
MANY OF THE THINGS THAT. WE
HAVE IN THIS BUDGET I TOO WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT AS SOMEONE
WHO. HAS HAS HAS SERVED ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE THERE'S
ACTUALLY MANY- LONG TERM ISSUES
WITH THE DRESS AS WELL- FOR
EXAMPLE ELIMINATE SUSPENSIONS
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
THAT WE CARRIED OVER YEAR AFTER
YEAR AFTER YEAR- ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE THINGS RELATE. HSS
AND DD IS MENTIONED. NOW THE
MEDICAID EXPANSIONS AND
ACTUALLY MAINTAIN THE PROP
FIFTY SIX INFRASTRUCTURE. BUT
AS CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I.
DEFINITELY WANT TO JUST POINT
OUT ALSO PRECIADO THE SUPPORT
OF THE SENATE AND THE- ASSEMBLY
AND THEN ALSO THE GREEN OF THE
GOVERNOR ON OUR API EQUITY
BUDGETS- THE API COMMUNITY HAS-
SUFFERED QUITE A BIT DURING
COVE IT- NOT JUST SOME COVERT
ALONE BUT UNFORTUNATELY FROM
ATTACKS AND FROM HATE- THIS.
BUILDS ON UNFORTUNATELY A
HISTORY OF- OF THIS- HERE IN
THIS COUNTRY IN CALIFORNIA BUT-
WE ARE NOW ABOUT TO TAKE A
HISTORIC STEP. IN OUR STATE
BUDGET TO TRY TO ADDRESS. THOSE
ISSUES- THROUGH THE A GUY
EQUITY- PROP- HUNDREDS MILLION-
INVESTMENTS- TO BEGIN
ADDRESSING MANY OF THESE
ISSUES. AND SO I DEFINITELY
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT AS CHAIR
OF THE PILOTS SLAVE CAUCUS. AND
FINALLY I KNOW THAT THIS IS ON
THE HEELS OF COVETED- AS WE
WATCH THE HEELS OF WHICH DOMINO
COVED BUDGET I ALSO JUST WANNA
RECOGNIZE THAT- THIS
LEGISLATURE FOUGHT FOR FUNDING
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH. SHE ATE THAT
THIS MORNING I HEARD FROM
FINANCE AND I KNOW THEY'VE
CREATED PRIOR HAD MADE THE
COMMITMENT TO OUR LEADERSHIP-
THE COMMITMENT FOR THREE
HUNDRED MILLION I'M GOING FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH STARTING WITH THE
FOLLOWING FISCAL YEAR END. ALSO
AN EFFORT TO BE SURE WE FIND
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
WITH FEDERAL FUNDING WHICH WERE
STILL GETTING FOR COVETED- THIS
COMING FISCAL YEAR AS WELL AND
THERE ARE ALSO OTHER
INVESTMENTS IN PUBLIC HEALTH
THAT ARE HAPPENING THIS YEAR
LIKE HONESTY EYES AND- EQUITY
AS WELL SO. WITH THAT I'D URGE
AND I VOTE ON SB ONE TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR PAM CENTER DOLLY. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
SUMMARIZE FOR MOMENT AND FIRST
OFF I WANT TO TAKE THE BUDGET
CHAIR- I LIKE- THE SIMILAR FROM
SENATE SENATOR FROM FRESNO- I
GOT THE OPPORTUNITY TO SIT ON
THE BUDGET IN A SUB COMMITTEE
SO I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS ALSO- THIS
IS THE LARGEST BUDGET IN THE
STATE'S HSTORY HUNTER NINETY
SIX BILLION DOLLARS A GENERAL
FUND. SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND THERE'S A LOT IN HERE
THERE'S A LOT TO IT THERE'S A
LOT TO LIKE THERE'S A LOT TO BE
FOR ME NERVOUS ABOUT ABOUT HOW
IT'S ACTUALLY GONNA BE
IMPLEMENTED. LET'S TAKE FOR
EXAMPLE THE SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS. IN BROADBAND. NOW
SOMEBODY WHO'S WORKED ON
BROADWAY AND YOU GUYS HAVE
HEARD ME TALK ABOUT BROADBAND
BUT HOW IS IT ACTUALLY GOING TO
GET TO THE GROUND AND HOW'S IT
GONNA AFFECT. THE CONSTITUENTS
THAT WE ALL SERVE AND THOSE WHO
ARE UNDER. THE UNDER SERVED OR
NOT SERVED. THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS. AND THERE'S GONNA BE A
LOT OF WORK. FROM THIS POINT
FORWARD ON HOW WE ACTUALLY.
DRIVE IT HOME. AND SO I WANT TO
JUST CHALLENGE FOR BROADBAND.
FOR PRISON REALIGNMENT. FOR
DROUGHT AND FIRE. DID MEMBERS
WELL I'M CHALLENGING YOU TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ACTUALLY DO A
GOOD JOB OF SHEPHERDING IT FROM
THIS POINT FORWARD BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S GOING TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR
CALIFORNIANS IS THAT WE
ACTUALLY STRETCH THIS MONEY OUT
AND WE GET THE SERVICES THAT WE
HAVE PROVIDED. IN THIS BUDGET
TO THEM. AND I WANT TO SHARE
ONE LAST THING THAT IS REALLY
DEAR TO ME I'M- AS YOU ALL
KNOW. A GENERATION OF MY FAMILY
FARM HERE IN CALIFORNIA I'M NOT
PLANNING ON LEAVING CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE HAVE. WHAT WE TALK ABOUT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. GIVING
US ALL THIS MONEY WE ARE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE ARE ALL
PARTICIPANTS IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND WE ARE IN THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. TWENTY EIGHT
POINT FIVE TRILLION DOLLARS IN
DEBT. THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A
SECOND THOSE WHO OF US THAT
HAVE CHILDREN AND ARE LOOKING
TO THE FUTURE FOR THEM. EVERY
SINGLE MAN WOMAN AND CHILD IN
AMERICA IS IN DEBT EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. ROSLYN DALLY
WHO IS ELEVEN YEARS OLD IS IN
DEBT EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. FOR THOSE YOU HAVE
SMALL CHILDREN BABIES THERE AND
AT EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WE MUST DO A GREAT JOB IN
STRETCHING OUR RESOURCES AND
GET THE SERVICE YOU NEED AND
START LOOKING AT A WAY TO DRAW
DOWN THE DEBT THERE WERE PILING
UP ON THE GENERATIONS THAT
FOLLOW US IF WE REALLY WANT TO
DO THE RIGHT THING. SO I WANT
TO JUST CHALLENGE YOU WITH THAT
I WANT TO SAY THERE ARE A LOT
OF GREAT THINGS THIS BUDGET BUT
I'M ALSO. WORRIED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
DELIVER WHAT WE SAY WE'RE GOING
TO DELIVER. A FEW YEARS BACK
FOR EXAMPLE WE PASSED A WATER
BOND. SEVEN A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS. TO BUILD TO BUILD
STORAGE. AND ACTUALLY PRODUCE
MORE WATER FOR CALIFORNIA. BUT
TODAY I'M NOT WHERE OF ONE
GALLON OF WATER THAT'S BEEN
CREATED MORE. SO THAT'S WHAT I
WANTED TO STAND UP AND SAY I
APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
BUT I THINK THE CHALLENGE NOW
IS MOVING FORWARD. AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE ACTUALLY DO WHAT
WE SAY WE'RE GOING TO DO AND
DELIVER THE SERVICES IN A-
EFFICIENT STREAMLINED MANNER TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS. THANK YOU ALL.
THANK YOU SENATOR DELHI CENTRE
TORONTO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I AM I'M VERY PROUD OF THE OUR
BUDGET- SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE THE
MEMBERS WE WORKED HARD ON
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
REFERENCED PUBLIC SAFETY
TRANSPORTATION LABOR EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND JUDICIAL I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES.
HI RISE BECAUSE I AM ESPECIALLY
PROUD. OF THIS BUDGET WE ARE
SENDING TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
TONIGHT. BECAUSE IT INCLUDES
FUNDING TO INCLUDE
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
AGES FIFTY AND OVER. AND INTO
THE FULL SCOPE OF MEDICARE L.
REGARDLESS OF STATUS. THIS
LATEST INCLUSION OF
CALIFORNIANS AS A RESULT OF
CONTINUED YEARS OF HARD WORK
AND ADVOCACY. MY HEALTH FOR ALL
BUSINESS ACADEMIA GRASSROOTS
COALITION PRIOR TO THIS THE
HEALTH FOR ALL COALITION HAD
SECURED THE INCLUSION OF YOUNG
CHILDREN INTO MEDICARE ALL IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN OUR LEGISLATURE
INCLUDED YOUNG ADULTS UP TO THE
AGES OF TWENTY FIVE. BUT UNTIL
NOW UNDOCUMENTED PARENTS OR
GRANDPARENTS. WHO TAKE THEIR
CHILD OR GRANDCHILD TO THE
DOCTOR COULD NOT GET. SERVICE
FOR THEMSELVES ONLY UNLESS IT
WAS AN EMERGENCY CARE. MORE
THAN HALF OF UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ARE PART OF MIXED
STATUS FAMILIES TWO THIRDS HAVE
LIVED IN THE US MORE THAN TEN
YEARS ALL CONTRIBUTING OVER
THREE BILLION DOLLARS AND LOCAL
AND STATE TAXES. THEY HELPED TO
FUND THE MEDICAL THAT THEY
COULD NOT ACCESS NOW THESE
CALIFORNIANS WILL FINALLY BE
ABLE TO ACCESS HEALTH CARE IF
AND WHEN THEY NEEDED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AS A WHOLE WILL BE
MORE PROSPEROUS PROSPEROUS AND
HEALTHIER. R. C. HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM WORKS BEST WHEN ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
PREVENTATIVE TREATMENT. I'M
GRATEFUL TO THE LEADERSHIP OF
OUR PRO TEM AND OUR GOVERNOR
FOR THEIR SUPPORT TO ADDRESS
THIS INJUSTICE. LET'S CONTINUE
TO REALIZE HEALTH CARE AS A
BASIC HUMAN RIGHT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER DRAWS- CENTER
HERTZBERG. THANKS VERY MUCH.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
MINUTE BUDGET CHAIR. IN EACH OF
THE SUB COMMITTEE CHAIRS OF
WORK SO HARD I WANT TO ADDRESS
A COUPLE POINTS IN. ADD SOME
CONTEXT AS WE DEAL WITH THIS
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGE OF
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS BUDGET
DOCUMENT WHICH GUIDES
CALIFORNIA. THE PRO TEM LAST
YEAR PUT TOGETHER A WORKING
GROUP OF ECONOMIC RECOVERY
INCLUDING MYSELF AND THE
SENATOR FROM VIRGINIA TEN
SENATORS FROM THIS HOUSE
FIFTEEN MEMBERS FROM THE OTHER
HOUSE ALL OF WHOM PUT TOGETHER
A ONE HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR
PACKAGE. BUT THE PACKAGE. WAS
ABOUT ECONOMIC RECOVERY. WE DID
NOT KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE WOULD
BRING. THAT IS ONE OF THE GREAT
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE IN THIS
GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF HOW OUR
BUDGET WORKS. THE MAYOR OF
SACRAMENTO FORMER P. T. WAS
HERE WHEN THERE WAS SIXTY
BILLION DOLLAR DEFICITS BY TWO
OF MY HISTORY BEING HERE
EXTRAORDINARY DEFICITS WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN IT MEANS IT'S A
HORTON SERVICES ARE CUT OFF IT
MEANS EMPLOYEES ARE FURLOUGHED
IT MEANS THAT THE COST OF
RESTARTING IS EXTRAORDINARY WE
HAVE THIS UNBELIEVABLY VOLATILE
SYSTEM. AND HERE WE FACE
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL DOLLARS
THAT WE HAVE AND THE
UNBELIEVABLE UNEXPECTED DOLLARS
THAT WE HAVE IN CAPITAL GAINS.
CRAZY AMOUNT OF MONEY. IT'S SO
FROM SOMEONE WITH MY
PERSPECTIVE WHAT I'M INTERESTED
IN IS IN ADDITION TO
SUPPLEMENTING SO MANY OF THE
SERVICES AND PROVIDING AND
FIXING SO MANY OF THE HOLES
THAT WE HAVE IN THE BUDGET WHAT
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IS A
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET FOR THE LONG
TERM. TWENTY FIVE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN RESERVES.
TWENTY FIVE POINT TWO BILLION.
IN THE OLD DAYS WE JUST HAD A
SMALL MAYBE A BILLION DOLLAR
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS REMEMBER
THIS A- SENATOR IN THE OLD DAYS
WE HAD A SMALL DOLLAR RESERVE.
UNDER THE A BUDGET. THAT WAS
REQUIRED NOW WE HAVE FOUR FOR
RESERVES WE HAVE ASSOCIATE WE
HAVE ONE FOR SOCIAL SAFETY NET.
EDUCATION THE BIG RAINY DAY
FUND PLUS THE RESERVE ACCOUNT.
UNPRECEDENTED BUT WHY IS THAT
NECESSARY. BECAUSE IT'S
RESPONSIBLE TO BE ABLE TO THINK
LONG TERM TO PROTECT AGAINST
THE VOLATILITY THAT WE FACE AND
THE IMPACT IT HAS EVERYWHERE.
WE HAVE PAID DOWN MY FIRST WHEN
I WAS GOING GOVERNMENT BEFORE.
WE HAD WITHIN WEEKS OF MY
ELECTION. A HUGE OBLIGATION
UNDER PROP NINETY EIGHT WE TAKE
OFF THAT OBLIGATION COMPLETELY
AND GIVEN US TOOLS FOR THOSE OF
US WHO WERE IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS. TO BE ABLE TO AS WE GO
FORWARD AND HAVE THIS
VOLATILITY TO BE ABLE TO BE
PREPARED FOR THAT. PAYING DOWN
DEBT HUGE RESERVES FORTY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS I THINK THE
NUMBER WAS. A ONE TIME REVENUES
FIXING A LOT OF UNDERLYING
PROBLEMS. BUT DOING IT IN A WAY
THAT UNDERSTANDS THE LONG TERM
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE. IN
CALIFORNIA. SO INDEED IS THE-
PRO TEM MENTIONED IS THE BUDGET
CHAIR MENTIONED IS THE CHAIR
SUBCOMMITTEE SHARES MENTION IN
TERMS OF FIXING A NUMBER OF
PROBLEMS. WANTED TO STEP BACK
AND LOOK AT THE LARGER
ARCHITECTURE SO THAT WE CAN
PROTECT FUTURE GENERATIONS. AS
WE DEAL WITH THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE TO FACE. THIS
EXPANDING GROWING CHANGING
CALIFORNIA WERE LOOK THE
FINANCIAL LANDSCAPE IS NOTHING
LESS THAN EXTRAORDINARY. AND OF
COURSE WE HAVE DEALT WITH SO
MANY OF THE ISSUES WERE
MENTIONED RELATED TO BUSINESS
AND RELATED. TO SOME OF THE
OTHER ASPECTS OF THE BUDGET TO
WORK TO KILL IT. BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAKE THAT
STATEMENT ABOUT THE LONG TERM
VIEW ABOUT THE RESPONSIBLE
BUDGETING ABOUT PROVIDING THE
NECESSARY TOOLS GOING FORWARD.
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
FACE CHALLENGES AS AS WE ALWAYS
HAVE DONE IN THE PAST AND FOR
THAT I WANTED TO ADD THAT MY
COMMENTS TO EXPRESS THAT
DIMENSION OF WHY I THINK. THIS
BUDGET HAS ELEGANCE IS
APPROPRIATE. AND I CAN STAND
AND PROUDLY VOTE FOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBERS. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG CENTER CALLED
LONGER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BUDGET- I'M PROUD OF THIS
BUDGET AND GRATEFUL TO. THE
CHAIR OF OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND ARE SOME CHAIRS FOR ALL OF
THE WORK THAT THEY DID I THINK.
YOU KNOW I'M A NEWLY ELECTED TO
THIS BODY AND I ACTUALLY THINK
IT'S KINDA NEAT THAT THE FIRST
REAL BUSINESS WE'VE DONE IN A
BODY AS A BODY HERE TOGETHER IS
TO VOTE ON A BUDGET THAT'S
GOING TO HELP ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS I MEAN. LIKE I
SAID I THINK THIS IS PRETTY
COOL. AND THERE ARE SOME GREAT
THINGS IN THIS BUDGET YOU KNOW
THERE ARE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A PUBLIC HOSPITALS.
THAT SERVE THE FOLKS THAT NEED
HEALTH CARE THE MOST. THERE'S
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GOING TO
THE INSTITUTE FOR REPRODUCTIVE%
HEALTH. IT'S IN THAT PARTICULAR
SPACE. FUNDING OUR MOBILE
CRISIS UNITS AMEN I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THE CRISIS ACT FOR
TWO YEARS. ALL I CAN SAY TO
THAT IS AMEN WE HAVE
HISTORICALLY FUNDED THE ARTS.
THE ARTS IN OUR ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HEAL US AND
EMBRACE US WHEN NO ONE ELSE
SEEMS TO DO IT. URBAN FARMS
SENIOR FARM PROGRAMS WE NOW
WILL HAVE A HOSPITAL IN SOUTH
LA. THAT HAS BEEN TREATING.
MORE HOMELESS AND LOW INCOME
PEOPLE IN LA THAN ANY OTHER
FACILITY. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO STRENGTHEN EFFORTS
TO KEEP OUR YOUTH OUT OF OUR
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM I SEE THIS
AS AN ECONOMIC JUSTICE BUDGET.
AND IN REALITY WE ARE WRITING
SOME SHIPS THAT HAVE BEEN
SINKING FOR A REALLY LONG TIME.
BECAUSE WE HAVE SKIRTED REALLY
DEEP AND MEANINGFUL INVESTMENTS
YOU ALL KNOW WE HAVE BEEN
ROBBING PETER TO PAY PAUL TO
KEEP THE LIGHTS ON FOR THIS
STATE FOR A REALLY LONG TIME
AND WE NOW HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DIG DEEPLY AND TO INVEST IN
COMMUNITIES THAT PROBABLY FEEL
LIKE WE HAVE FORGOTTEN THEM. I
SEE THIS BUDGET. AS A DOWN
PAYMENT ON A NEW KIND OF
CALIFORNIA. WHERE ALL BOATS ARE
LIFTED AND I'M HOPING THAT WE
WILL STAY COMMITTED TO THIS I
AM GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE THE
SURPLUS AND I AM GRATEFUL THAT
WE HAVE DECIDED TO DOUBLE DOWN
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE TO SAY
I SEE YOU I SEE YOU CALIFORNIA.
THEN I AM INVESTED IN MAKING
THINGS RIGHT THAT WE HAVE LEFT
MARGINALIZED OR THAT WE HAVE
PUT DUCT TAPE ON AND WE HAVE
HOPED THAT NOTHING WOULD POP
OFF AND START LEAKING LAST YEAR
THINGS LEAKED. AND SOME THINGS
THANK. AND WE ARE HERE TO LIFT
THEM UP SO I AM PROUD OF THIS
BUDGET GRATEFUL THAT I'M HERE
WHEN WE HAVE MONEY THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO GIVE IT ACROSS THIS
STATE AND I URGE I VOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER CALM WATER SENATOR
MAN. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I WANT TO THANK OUR LEADERS-
BOTH ON THE BUDGET STAFF- AS
WELL AS A MAN APPROACHED HIM
AND- FOR ALL YOUR HARDWARE IN
MAJORITY LEADER OF COURSE FOR
ALL YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS
BUDGET- I AM CAME INTO OFFICE
AT THE BEGINNING THIS YEAR AND-
WE HAVE COURSES FACE. IT SO
MANY CHALLENGES OVER THE PAST
YEAR AND A HALF- CHALLENGES
THAT DIDN'T HAVE A PLAYBOOK AND
THERE WAS OF COURSE A LOT OF
SECOND GUESSING A LOT OF MONDAY
MORNING QUARTERBACKING ABOUT
WHETHER CALIFORNIA IS DOING THE
RIGHT THING WHETHER WE SHOULD
BE MORE LIKE FLORIDA OR TEXAS
OR OTHER STATES AROUND THE
COUNTRY. AND YET AT THIS POINT
IT SEEMS CLEAR WE ARE WELL
POSITIONED TO MERGE MORE
STRONGLY THAN ANY OTHER STATE-
WE HAVE ECONOMIC MIGHT BEHIND
US RIGHT NOW AND THE QUESTION
IS WHAT WE DO ABOUT THAT. NOW
THEY SAY THAT BUDGETS ARE
REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES AND
THAT'S WHY I WAS SO PROUD TO
VOTE FOR THIS BUDGET EARLIER
TODAY AND BUDGET COMMITTEE.
BECAUSE TO ME THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE FISCALLY PRUDENT
BUDGET THAT BALANCES THE SHORT
TERM PRIORITIES AND WE HAVE A
LOT OF SHORT TERM PRIORITIES
COMING OUT OF IT. WITH THE LONG
TERM INVESTMENTS THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE. NOW I WANT TO BUILD ON
THE COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BEAVER BECAUSE I AGREE
WITH THEM WE HAVE TWENTY EIGHT
POINT SOMETHING BILLION
TRILLION DOLLARS IN DEBT IN
THIS COUNTRY. AND THAT IS
OUTRAGEOUS AND I WERE ABOUT
WHAT MY KIDS ON HERE. BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ASK HOW WE GOT
HERE AND WE GOT HERE BECAUSE
THERE WERE TOO MANY PEOPLE THAT
ARGUE FOR GET RICH QUICK
SCHEMES LET'S GIVE MONEY THE
RICHEST AND THAT'LL PAY FOR
ITSELF IT WILL BE ALL STRONGER
CIRCLE. AND AS A RESULT WE DIS
INVESTED IN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THIS COUNTRY IN THE STATE.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO
INVESTING IN OUR LONG TERM
PRIORITIES AND ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT CALIFORNIA IS SO
STRONGLY PUT TODAY. TO DO SO
WELL. WELL THE RESORT. SO
STRONG IS BECAUSE WE INVESTED
HEAVILY IN OUR EDUCATION HIGHER
ED. AND OUR INFRASTRUCTURE. WE
HAVE TO MAKE THAT DOWN PAYMENT
AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID BEFORE.
BECAUSE THAT IS IMPORTANT WE
HAVE THIS HISTORIC SURPLUS. AND
WE HAVE A HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY
TO TRY TO INVEST. TO BUILD. THE
BACKBONE OF OUR FUTURE
PROSPERITY. AND SHARED
PROSPERITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. SO I WILL VOTE
YES ON THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THIS IS A VOTE FOR OUR
FUTURE IN THIS STATE. THANK
YOU. I THINK YOU SAID IRVINE
CENTER LAYERED. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THIS IS THE SECOND
DEBATE WE'VE HAD ON THIS BILL
TODAY- AND IT WAS INTERESTING
TO REFLECT THAT THIS MORNING
AND- BUDGET COMMITTEE THERE WAS
A SUGGESTION THAT MAYBE THE
PROCESS WAS OPAQUE OR PEOPLE
HAD NOT BEEN INVOLVED IN AND IT
WAS CLOSED OFF HERE AT THE END.
AND YET JUST SPEAKING FOR THE
EDUCATION BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
WE HAD THIRTEEN HERE SO OVER
THE LAST FEW MONTHS WE HEARD
TESTIMONY FROM HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WHEN WE
VOTED IN THE END WE VOTED ON
ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED INDIVIDUAL
ITEMS ALL OF WHICH WE HAD
DISCUSSED AND VETTED IN THE
PROCESS. AND IT'S SIGNIFICANT
THAT WHEN WE HEARD THE
TESTIMONY WE RESPONDED. WE HAD
TESTIMONY IN A JOINT HEARING
WITH SENATOR ARGUMENTS
COMMITTEE ON CHILD CARE. AND
PEOPLE SAID THIS IS THE TICKET
TO ECONOMIC SECURITY OR HELP
FOR SO MANY PEOPLE IF IT IS
OFFERED WE RESPOND TO IT WITH
MORE SLOTS AND BETTER PAY. IT
WAS SUGGESTED IN THOSE HEARINGS
BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT IT
JUST WASN'T RESPONSIBLE TO TAKE
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT WE
WERE GIVEN AND NOT PAY OFF ALL
THE DEFERRALS. THAT AT A TIME
WHEN WE WERE FLUSH THAT'S THE
TIME TO PAY OFF DEBT. AND WE
DID WE RESPOND IT'S IN THIS
BUDGET WHEN IT WASN'T IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET. AND IT WAS
SUGGESTED THAT STUDENT AID IS
NARROW THAT IT IS OFFERED TO A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE AND
WE'RE ADDING AT LEAST A HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND MAYBE AN EQUAL
AMOUNT MORE. TO REALLY MOVE
MANY MANY CALIFORNIANS TO A
DEBT FREE COLLEGE. AND IT WAS
SUGGESTED THAT FOR TWENTY YEARS
THE AGRICULTURAL ADVISORS AND
THE PHARMACY VISORS AND YOU SEE
I GET EXTENSION HAS BEEN
STAGNANT LAYING PEOPLE OFF AND
NOT HELPING OUR FARMERS. WE ARE
BRINGING IT BACK TO WHERE I
WAS YEARS AND YEARS AGO IN
RESPONSE TO THAT TESTIMONY. AND
THERE WERE PARENTS OF KIDS
WHERE THEY HAD APPLIED TO UC
AND THERE WEREN'T ENOUGH SPACES
BECAUSE THEY WERE OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS IN A DISPROPORTIONATE
NUMBER TAKING THOSE SPACES AND
WE HAVE A PROPOSAL HERE THAT IS
IN THE BUDGET. TO DEAL WITH THE
THREE CAMPUSES THAT HAVE THE
MOST OUT OF STATE STUDENTS AND
BACK FILL IT AND TOGETHER WITH
ADDITIONAL ENROLLMENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
PROVIDE MANY MORE SPACES. FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. AND WE
HEARD OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
ABOUT CHILD DEVELOPMENT ABOUT
THE NEED FOR PRE K. OR MORE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN FOR
MORE CHILD CARE OPPORTUNITIES
PRIOR TO KIDS COMING INTO
SCHOOL AND IN A HISTORIC WAY.
THIS BUDGET ADDRESSES THAT.
ADDITIONALLY WHEN WE ADOPTED
THE BUDGET AROUND JUNE
FIFTEENTH IT WAS SUGGESTED.
THAT THAT BUDGET WAS
IRRESPONSIBLE THERE WAS A
BUDGET LIKE TWENTY YEARS AGO
LIKE A BUDGET THAT LED INTO THE
DOLDRUMS POLITICALLY IN
CALIFORNIA TWENTY YEARS AGO.
WELL THIS BUDGET HAS A RECORD
AMOUNT OF RESERVES TWENTY FIVE
BILLION IN TOTAL BUT IS MORE
THAN IS EVER EVEN CONTEMPLATED
ANYTIME WE HAVE ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS THAT GOES TO BUSINESSES
AND WITH STIMULUS TO
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC IT REALLY HELPS LIFT
PEOPLE UP. AND THEN WE PAY OFF
THE DEFERRALS WE PAY OFF DEBT
AND OR OR THINGS LIKE THE TWO
BILLION DOLLAR ACCOUNT FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION BUILDINGS WERE
NORMALLY. WE WOULD BE PUTTING
THOSE IN BONDS AND WOULD BE
INCURRING TO AT THIS TIME WE'RE
MAKING THE EXPENDITURE IN A
DEBT FREE WAY GETTING A 100% OF
THE VALUE AND NOT INCURRING
INTEREST PAYMENTS. AND SO WE
HERE WE GO WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBLE FISCALLY PRUDENT
BUDGET WE RESPONDED TO THE
PUBLIC WE DO SO MANY THINGS-
ONE TIME IN RESPONSE TO THE
FACT THAT IT'S ONE TIME MONEY.
BUT THEN WE ARE WE GO AFTER THE
PROBLEMS THAT HAVE BEEN
INTRACTABLE FOR SO LONG AND
BUDGET FOR IMPACT AND MAKE A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE WE'VE
BEEN WAITING FOR DECADES TO
HAVE STUDENT AID THAT HELPS
PEOPLE. WE'VE BEEN WAITING TO
REACH STORE OUR SCHOOLS TO THE
LEVELS FINANCIALLY THEY WERE
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND WE'RE
ADDING 5% AT ALL LEVELS BUT
WITH CHILD CARE WE'RE DOING A
HISTORIC CONDITION. WITH
HOMELESSNESS WE'RE GOING TO ADD
IT IN AN IMPACTFUL WAY WITH
MORE RESOURCES. THAN COULD EVEN
BE CONTEMPLATED. WHICH DO AID
BRING HOME OF MORE PEOPLE. AND
WITH OUR OWN CRISES DUE TO
CLIMATE WITH WILDFIRE AND
DROUGHT WE HAVE MONEY TO
ADDRESS THOSE IN SIGNIFICANT
WAYS SO THIS BUDGET IS REALLY
PRUDENT. WITH REGARD TO DATA
WITH REGARD TO RESERVES. THE
THIS IS ADDRESSES OUR MOST
PRESSING PROBLEMS AND IT MOVES
US AHEAD IN A WAY THAT I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY HAS HAD A BUDGET
LIKE THIS IN FRONT OF THEM FOR
GENERATIONS IF NOT MUCH MORE.
WE SHOULD BE PROUD OF THIS
BUDGET AND I'M GONNA PROBABLY
CAST AND I FOCUSED. THANK YOU
CENTER LAYERED SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT HAS
AS A FORMER MEMBER OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR ALL HEIR
WORK I KNOW IT'S A IT'S A METS
AMOUNT OF TIME LABOR- TAKING A
LOT OF INPUT AND WHEN I ANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND WE'VE
HEARD THE WORD HISTORIC TONIGHT
HOW ABOUT THIS BUDGET. AND
HONESTLY. IT'S IS HISTORIC IN
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT WE'VE
LOST. WHEN I DO THIS BUDGET
HIGHS I THINK THE TWO THINGS I
THINK THE BANDAIDS IN
ANTIBIOTICS. THIS BUDGET. IS
NOT INVESTING IN ORDINARY
CALIFORNIANS IS INVESTING IN
THE GOVERNOR'S A SHORT TERM
POLITICAL FEATURE. TO THE
DETRIMENT OF LONG TERM
DETRIMENT OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
YOU KNOW US SENATE REPUBLICANS
WE OFFERED LOGICAL SOLUTIONS.
THAT WOULD HAVE HELPED ORDINARY
CALIFORNIANS BY SAVING SMALL
BUSINESSES. PROTECTING JOBS
REFORMING ET DE ESTABLISH
ESTABLISHING A GAS TAX HOLIDAY
AND BRINGING ACCOUNTABILITY TO
ALL FIRE BUT WE WERE WE ARE
SHUT OUT OF THE PROCESS. I WANT
TO REMIND YOU WE GET PICKED ON
A LOT OF THE SLOWER BECAUSE
THERE'S ONLY NINE OF US. BUT WE
REPRESENT A MILLION PEOPLE EACH
US NINE MILLION PEOPLE THAT'S
THE SAME SIZE AS A STATE IN NEW
JERSEY. US AS A REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS WE HAVE TEN ELECTORAL
VOTES IF WE WERE OUR OWN STATE.
AND SO. IT IS IT IS IT WE COULD
WE COULD HAVE DONE MORE WE
COULD DATE IS ARE GOOD THINGS
IN THIS BILL OF COURSE THERE IS
MENTION THIS KIND OF MONEY
THERE THERE HAS TO BE. BUT I'VE
BEEN UP HERE LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM STOCK TO NINE YEARS NOW
AND I'M TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW
WE'RE NOT IT'S JUST NOT GONNA
BE TODAY'S NOT COULD BE
TOMORROW IT COULD BE NEXT WEEK.
BUT THIS IS DEJA VU ALL OVER
AGAIN BECAUSE A FEW YEARS FROM
NOW WE'RE GONNA BE BACK THE
SAME PLACE HIGHER TAXES AND
THEN HAVING TO CUT PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A
SUSTAINABLE PATHWAY FORD. TO
BRING- TO BRING ALL OF ALL
BOATS UP AS MENTIONED EARLIER
SO THIS BUDGET ACTUALLY MAKES
ME SAD IS NOT MAKE ME HAPPY
AND- I KNOW THERE IS YOU KNOW A
BIG EFFORT INTO IT BUT IT'S NOT
GOING TO GET THE JOB DONE. FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILK SENATOR
NIELSEN. MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES
GENTLEMAN THE SENATE. I WILL
STAND BY MY REMARKS
HISTORICALLY AND PERSISTENTLY
OVER THE BUDGET PROCESS. I
CONSIDER THAT STILL
DISAPPOINTING. BUT SETTING THAT
ASIDE AS WE WIND UP THIS BUDGET
I WANT TO THANK THE PROTEST FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SERVE ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE DOESN'T HAVE
MOST OF MY CAREER. IT'S THE
TOUGHEST COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE BY FAR AND ALL
MATTER AND WORRIES. AND THE
LABORS ARE MIGHTY BUT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS CAN BE MIGHTY AS
WELL ON THAT COMMITTEE SO I
APPRECIATE THAT OPPORTUNITY. I
ALSO HAVE ENJOYED SERVING WITH
THE CHAIR. AS I HAVE HER
PREDECESSORS DATING ALL THE WAY
BACK TO SENATOR AL RATO. WHOSE
FIRST BIG CHALLENGE I THINK IS
A SENATOR AND HE'D BEEN THERE A
LONG TIME. WAS DEALING WITH
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN AND THAT
WAS THE YEAR THAT I ARRIVED IN
THIS INSTITUTION. WELL OUT OF
COURSE IS ANOTHER GEM. OF A
LEADER THERE'S A BUST OF HIM I
THINK IN THE BUDGET OFFICE
STILL AROUND TO REMIND US OF
AL'S EFFORTS. ESPECIALLY
ENJOYED MY TIME WITH MARK LENO.
HAVE YOU WOULD NOT THINK THAT
HE AND I WOULD AGREE ON MUCH OF
ANYTHING BUT WE SURELY DID.
IT'S A GOOD PROCESS. IT HAS
BEEN AND IT STILL CAN BE I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE A VERY. GREAT
COMMOTE COMMENDATION TO THE
DEMOCRATIC BUDGET STAFF AND THE
REPUBLICAN BUDGET STAFF. THE
DEMOCRATIC STAFF OF REALLY GONE
OUT OF THEIR WAY TO BE HELPFUL
TO THE REPUBLICAN STAFF GETTING
THIS INFORMATION. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. THEY DIDN'T
HAVE TO DO THAT AND IT'S BEEN
HELPFUL TO US TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION TO
PROCEED IN OUR HEARINGS. SO I
CREATE THAT AND I WANT TO THANK
THE- THE CHAIRS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEES BECAUSE THEY HAVE
A HARDER JOB TOO BECAUSE
THEY'VE GOT TO PREPARE FOR EACH
OF THE HEARINGS AND THERE ARE A
LOT OF HEARING. I AGREE WITH
THAT. I WILL ASK SO IN THE
FUTURE THAT WE ALLOW MORE
PUBLIC INPUT BEYOND THAT. I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS
AND THE PRO TEM AND THE BUDGET
CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE AND WORK WITH. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON. SENATOR WIENER.
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I
SAYS I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS BUDGET ON SO MANY LEVELS.
THIS BUDGET HAS HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS IN HOUSING HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS IN MENTAL HEALTH
INCLUDING FOR OUR CHILDREN FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS. FOR KIDS WHO
HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING SO
MIGHTILY. DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
HUGE INVESTMENTS IN CHILDCARE
THIS IS. A BUDGET TO BE VERY
VERY. EXCITED ABOUT. AND SO I
WANT TO THANK THE LEADERSHIP IN
OUR BUDGET COMMITTEES FOR
REALLY AND THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ASSEMBLY. FOR COMING TOGETHER
AND NOT JUST SAYING WE HAVE A
LOT OF MONEY. TO SPEND IT WITH
SPENDING AN EXTREMELY TARGETED
STRATEGIC WAYS THAT ARE GOING
TO HAVE TANGIBLE BENEFITS. AND
MAKE THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
BETTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING THE ANSWERS
CAN REMAIN CLOSE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MADAM PRESIDENT AND ALL
THE MEMBERS WHO HAVE COMMENTED.
THIS BOLD AND RESPONSIBLE GOOD
NEWS BUDGET WAS A HUGE
UNDERTAKING. AND FIRST I WANT
TO THANK THE BUDGETS OF CHAIRS
THEY'VE DESCRIBED THE AMOUNT OF
WORK IN THE VARIOUS OF THE
MEMBERS HAVE DESCRIBED. THE
SIXTY OR MORE HEARINGS THAT
THEY HELPED TO VETS ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT PROPOSALS TO GET
PUBLIC AND STAKEHOLDER INPUT
INPUT AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA CRUZ POINTED OUT. ENDED
UP WITH MANY REVISIONS AND
CHANGES TO THE BUDGET THAT YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU BASED ON THAT
INPUT THAT CAME IN- I WANT TO
JOIN WITH THE PRO TEM. IN
EXTENDING MY SINCERE THANKS TO
THE BOARD THAT THOUSANDS AND
I'M TALKING THOUSANDS OF HOURS
THAT. OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE
STAFF AND ALL THE LEGISLATIVE
STAFF WHO ASSISTED THE LA- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
OTHER STAFF INTHE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. THAT VETTED PROPOSED
DISCUSSED AND PRODUCED THIS
TRANSFORMATIVE AND BOLD BUDGET
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU SANDERS GAINER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ACTIONS I BASICS NO BACKER I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I CAN BUY A-
HI CORTESE HI DALLY. DODD HI
DURAZO HI ADNAN HI BLAZER I CAN
DOLLARS HI GROSS. HERTZBERG HI
WITH SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES
NO CAMCORDER HI LAYERED HI
LLEVA HI THE MON. HI MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH. PAN
HI FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT. HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN I AM
BERG HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER HI WELL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE OF THE MEMBERS. DALLY GROVE.
MELINDA'S A CHILL ABOUT FIVE
THIRTY ONE NEWS FIVE HE SIMPLY
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING BACK TO
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER TWO
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM ONE HUNDRED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL ONE THIRTY NINE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO
ECONOMIC RELIEF AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELIEVES THE BUDGET. CENTERS
CAN THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS EIGHT SP ONE THIRTY
pSTIMULUS TO TRAILER BILL THAT
ESTABLISHES TAX REBATE
PAYMENTS. TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
RELIEF TO OUR LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME CALIFORNIANS THE KEY
PROVISIONS ARE IT PROVIDES A
ONE TIME STIMULUS PAYMENT OF
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS TO ANYONE
MAKING SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND OR
BELOW WHO DID NOT. ALREADY
RECEIVED A GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS PAYMENTS AND IF YOU
RECALL WE TOOK AN EARLY ACTION
AND PROVIDED GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS ONE. IT ALSO PROVIDES
A ONE TIME PAYMENT OF FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO ANYONE
MAKING SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND OR
LESS COMPLAIN A DEPENDENT SO
SOME OF THESE RECIPIENTS WILL
RECEIVE. ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED IF THEY ALSO QUALIFY
FOR THE FIRST SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR PAYMENT. IT PROVIDES A
ONE TIME STIMULUS PAYMENT OF
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO ANYONE
WHO MAKES SEVENTY FIVE K. OR
LESS. WHO CLAIMS A DEPENDENT
AND FILES THEIR RETURN WITH THE
FEDERAL INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER. THESE
RECIPIENTS MAY ALSO RECEIVE A
TOTAL OF ONE THOUSAND BECAUSE
THEY MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR BOTH
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR BUCKETS. IN
TOTAL THESE PAYMENTS ARE
EXPECTED TO PROVIDE EIGHT POINT
ONE BILLION IN DIRECT RELIEF TO
MILLIONS OF LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS. SO
COMBINED WITH THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS. ONE ACTION THAT WE
TOOK EARLIER THIS YEAR WE ARE
PROVIDING APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN
POINT EIGHT BILLION IN DIRECT
PAYMENTS TO A ESTIMATED FIFTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT I ASK FOR
YOUR ARRIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
DONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI ATTENDEES I BASE. BECKER HI
PORGES NO BRADFORD I COME BY
OTHER HI CORTESE I DALLY NO DOT.
HI THERE AWESOME HI EGGMAN HI
GLASER HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HER TADO I JONES NO CAN LONGER.
I LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. NO PHOTO OF
BOTH I CAN I FORTUNE TINO. HI
RALPH HI RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN I AM BERG HI WHITE HOUSE
E. FIVE WINNER I WILL. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FAITH NO. WE FELT HI. FIVE
THIRTY ONE KNOWS EIGHT EXCUSE
ME I HAVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS
EIGHT DECEMBER MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING THE FILE
AND ONE OF TWO S. TWO ONE FORTY
SIX MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY SIX BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT RELATING
TO CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL REALLY DOES
THE BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SP ONE FORTY SIX IS A
TRAILER BILL THAT MAKES CHANGES
TO THE FINANCING OF OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY FACILITIES SPECIFICALLY
pREVENUE BOND THE THIRTY FIRST
THE HEALTHCARE FACILITY.
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM PROJECTS AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION.
INSTITUTIONS IT ALSO DECREASES
THE LEASE REVENUE AUTHORITY FOR
COUNTY JAIL CONSTRUCTION
PROGRAMS BY TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE MILLION DUE TO
AWARD RELINQUISHMENT AND ON
AWARDED FUNDS AND WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I
BASE NO BACKER. I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
COURTESY HI DOLLY. DODD HI
DURAZO HI ADNAN HI PLEASE SIR
HI CONSOLIDATES I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG HI WAY SO HI HER TADO.
HI JONES. NO CAN LONGER.
LAYERED HI LLEVA I WILL MOAN I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MEN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH. NO PAM HI FORTUNE TINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN HI AMBERG I Y. CASKEY
FIVE WINNER I WILL. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. TALLY
NO. CAN LONGER HI. FIVE THIRTY
ONE NEWS NINE THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE AND ONE OH FIVE SP ONE
FIFTY EIGHT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. WITH SENATE BILL
ONE FIFTY EIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO
HAZARDOUS WASTE WASTE AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL REALLY DOES
THE BUDGET. CENTERSGONNA THANK
YOU AND NOW TO PRESIDENT SP ONE
FIFTY EIGHT IS A TRAILER BILL
THAT PROVIDES STRUCTURAL
GOVERNANCE AND FEE REFORM TO
OUR DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ALSO KNOWN
AS BTS SEEIN THAT TELL REFERRED
TO IT FROM THIS POINT ON. THIS
BILL IT'S BEEN SEVERAL YEARS IN
THE MAKING OVER THE PAST DECADE
THE TSC HAS RECEIVED NUMEROUS
COMPLAINTS FROM THE PUBLIC DAN
FROM ITS REGULATED ENTITIES
ABOUT ITS PERMITTING PROGRAM.
DGSE AS RESULT HELD MEETINGS
WITH PUBLIC INPUT REGULATED
COMMUNITY STAKE HOLDERS TO
IDENTIFY AND UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
CONDUCTED NUMEROUS HEARINGS ON
DTS SEES INTERNAL CONTROLS ITS
BUSINESS PRACTICES. AND ITS
BASIC STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS AND
THESE EFFORTS AND MORE
CULMINATED IN THIS BILL WHICH
ADDRESSES CONCERNS ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
LONG TERM STABILITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE FUNDING FOR
ITS PERMITTING PROGRAM.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
ESTABLISHES THE BOARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY WITHIN THE
TSC IT ALSO RESTRUCTURES AND
INCREASES CHARGES THAT SUPPORT
THE HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT
ACCOUNTS. AND IT RESTRUCTURES
AND INCREASES THE TAX THAT
SUPPORTS THE TALKS TOXIC
SUBSTANCES. CONTROL ACCOUNT. IT
PROVIDES FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND OVER THREE YEARS
TO SUPPORT BROWNFIELD CLEANUPS
AND INVESTIGATIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AND PROVIDES THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND OVER
THREE YEARS AS A LOAN TO DGSE
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THE CLEAN
UP OF THE BACKSIDE HAZARDOUS
WASTE FACILITY. AND THIS BILL
REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS VOTE
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR RIVALS.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA. HI
AT KINS. I PLEASE NOTE BACKER.
HI FOR JUST NO BRADFORD I COME
BY ADAM HI COURTESY. HI DALLY
NO DOT. HI THERE ARE SO. EGGMAN
HI GLAZER HI CONDOLENCES HI
GROVE NO HERTZBERG HI WAY SO ON
HI HR TADO. JONES. KAMMERER HI
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON
FIVE MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO
MAN. HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. NO A
SHOW OF BOTH NO PAN. HI
FOURTEEN TINA HI ROSS HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER HI STERN HI AMBERG.
WHITE HOUSE SKIING HI WINNER HI
WELL. NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THEY'RE AWESOME HI.
HER TADO. JONES NO. AMBERG BUYS
TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING BACK TO TWO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR RICHARD
MIKE UP SET SENATOR MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY EIGHT I AM
AGAIN MAKING A MOTION TO
WITHDRAW AS YOUR FIVE FROM THE
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE AND
BROUGHT TO THE SENATE FLOOR SO
WE CAN HAVE A FULL AND RIGOROUS
DEBATE IT HAS BEEN. FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO DAYS
NOW. SINCE THIS EMERGENCY ORDER
WENT INTO EFFECT FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO DAYS DURING WHICH
THE LEGISLATURE HAS WILLINGLY.
SUBORDINATED ITSELF TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH FOR FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO DAYS.
NEARLY 60% OF CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
NEARLY 60% OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE TO GET A VACCINE
HAVE RECEIVED ONE. PEOPLE ARE
GOING BACK TO WORK. IT'S TIME
TO END THE STATE OF EMERGENCY I
ASK FOR YOUR IRA AND I FEEL
LIKE THE GOOD SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES IS GETTING AGREE WITH
ME TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER MELINDA'S SENATOR
HERTZBERG. MATURE YOUR **** FOR
A NO VOTE. HERTZBERG'S ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE SENATOR MELINDA
IS ASKING FOR AN I. VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN NO ARCHULETA. NO ATKINS NO
BASE. I BACKER NO FORGES HI
BRADFORD. NO BY ADAM NO CORTESE
NO DALLY HI TODD. NO THEY'RE
ALSO NO ADMIN NO GLAZER NO
GONZALEZ NO GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG NO WAY SO A LITTLE
KNOWN HER TADO. NO JONES I CAN
LONGER NO LAYERED NO LLEVA NO
THE MON NO REQUIRE NO MELINDA'S
I MEN. NO NEWMAN NO NIELSEN HI
A SHOW OF. HI PAM NO FORTINO.
NO ROSS. NO RUBIO. NO SKINNER
NO STERN NO- BURKE NO WAY
CASKEY. NO WINNER. NO WAY OUT.
HI. FIVE NINE NEWS THIRTY ONE
THE MOTION FAILS SENATOR DODD
FOR WHAT PURPOSE TO RISE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- THROUGH
BECAUSE THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
FILE NUMBER NINETY FROM THE
CONSECUTIVE- RETURNED TO THIRD
READING. THANK YOU SENATOR
DASCHLE DESCO NOTE ANYTHING
ELSE UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS CENTER ACTIONS THE
DISK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION
SCHEDULED FOR THIS THURSDAY
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT
NINE AM. THE SENATE WILL BE
ADJOURNED WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY AT NINE AM HAVE A GOOD
EVENING MEMBERS.